l'épisode de cette semaine et présenté
par police lipdub est ce que tu sais qu
est-ce qui est dégueulasse je dire
quelque chose qui va qui qui va te
rendre tu vas tu rends dans l'ex
utiliser un matelas peut peser après
quelques années peut peser jusqu'à deux
fois sont pour à cause des bactéries des
acariens puis de la peau morte sur un
matelas s'est tassé de degen
oovoo fait des allergies aux acariens
fait que c'est comme et comme tu es un
petit d'abord et anti acariens mais
citons matelas cumule deux fois son
poids en bactéries parnac à rien si
dégueulasse police l'ip ont un
traitement anti bactérien antimicrobiens
pardon qui permet de réduire
drastiquement la quantité de en fait de
microbes et d'acariens et ainsi de suite
et ainsi pardon réduire les allergies et
aussi le sentiment des galas de dormir
sur des microbes imagine seulement un
lit de microbes
c'est dégueu puis en plus d'avoir le
traitement antimicrobien police libre
offre des matelas à la fine pointe de la
technologie fait au québec on a
désormais police lit-on les avoir il ya
des gens qui nous écrivent qu'ils
achètent leurs lauriers qui reçoivent
puis un rien on a eu des témoignages
d'un gars qui disait qui a vu la
meilleure nutrimaine de toute sa vie
après avoir reçu son arrêt pour leslie
accueille le client est satisfait
l'autre jour j'ai croisé quelqu'un puis
la personne affichant un style goadec
les terres appauvri le quitte pas maluku
watts y parle c'est la police liant ces
malades mais effectivement on est reposé
on est frais dispos puis on a loin
d'avoir mal ou grâce à paul islip donc
merci la gagne ne pas laisser mon nom
un code promo pour vous qui se trouve à
être gelée juste ici le o s
f 25 pour 25 % de rabais sur votre
commande
excluant les sommiers et cette offre est
valide jusqu'au 26 octobre donc
profitez-en utiliser un code promo pour
passer les moeurs d'une semaine et vauvy
loin des microbes et à carré merci pour
les productions du studio sfr vient venu
au sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter date super
content rémois dôme plantes
si vous voulez nous encourager
abonnez-vous à notre plateforme pétrone
en ce moment alors où est ce qu'on se
parle
là on a un podcast avec virginie porter
un podcast victoria charlton qui sont
disponibles exclusivement à 90 p tu en
fais qu'aller voir sur le lien va être
dans la description du podcast sinon
cette semaine d'un super jeu de nos cils
et encore moins un filtre ou est ce
qu'on parle encore plus profondément
tepa de 82 x puis on a tellement étroit
aucun filtre à tulle c'est la chose avec
le moins de films que vous allez en
temps c'est que fortune vie c'est comme
l' endroit sur la planète où il y en a
moins de titres parce que attendus sont
blague à part l'attaché carré des
fontaines qui est une militante qui
tenait notre peau est une comédienne
innu grand plaisir est grand privilège
de la recevoir et venues dans toute sa
sagesse son savoir son sens tant que son
charisme nous parler de sa culture
on peut parler bien sûr du décès
tragique de joyce et chaque one puis
tout ce que ça cache en fait ce décès le
le racisme au québec le racisme
systémique jose jose utilisé ces mots
que le bo d'onna dont le vol de mort
des conversations aussi parlé d'une des
neuf natacha qui qu'à médine dans cette
série-là puis son personnage puis l
espèce de dualité qu'elle a eu
l'hésitation qu'elle a eu à faire
accepter ce rôle là qui peut paraître à
première vue stéréotypé mais qui
finalement va déconstruire ces
stéréotypes l'opsis des préconçues le
pour faire vraiment cheminée le
téléspectateur à travers la série on a
parlé de culture autochtone d'histoire
c'était super intéressant mots de ph en
bon ah bon québécois de souche pense
qu'on a su écouter tes poser des
questions puis les laisser la parole à
natacha qui est qui qui qui skie sa
parole est très importante je pense fait
qu'un grand prix village encore une fois
pour nous 2020 était de l'année de
marbre mais je pense que c'est une
excellente occasion de se préparer pour
un 2021 de renouveau puis des
conversations comme celles là sont ultra
importante pour tout ceux et celles qui
sont avec nous avec la sans filtre on
vous aime partager la conversation
écoutez écoutez bon bah casse bonne
écoute
[Musique]
ben merci d'être là merci merci beaucoup
d'être là ça nous fait extrêmement
plaisir d'autres se voir sur notre
podcast les les dernières semaines ont
dû quand même à être acide demandante en
termes d'énergie pour toi
comment comment ça se pense qu'au match
mais sérieusement c'est depuis deux
trois jours les gens me demandent
comment s'est dit ça allait bien jusqu'à
temps que la nouvelle des deux enfants
wendat qui arrive puis c'est comme
encore une autre enfant
ouais tu sens que tu remontes en tout et
comment qu'est en train de passer au
travers pied d'émerger titre le bac
c'est comme tomber parterre d'enfants
grâce à ses seules feeling mais sinon je
réfléchis beaucoup mais je me dis en
fait c'est sur soi pour un gars parce
que ça vient mettre en lumière aussi
celle là c'est sorti ce matin le cac
il ya eu plusieurs signalements à la dpj
il ya eu plusieurs moments où la mère a
tenté de faire quelque chose puis de
dénoncer ou deux de sauver ces enfants
que ça peut fonctionner donc le service
les services de protection de l'enfance
ou là de la jeunesse n'ont pas
fonctionné ont plus d'un mois encore
échoué oui c'est ça il échoue et ça
c'est le mot que j'ai cherché parce
qu'il ya le terme en anglais comme de
system for you fuck your children mais
c'est ce chercheur français de faire ma
taille je sais quoi on le trouve jouer
mais depuis en fait qu une bouchée côté
le bushi pitt n'a fontaine du côté du
manitoba et de l'alberta et de la
saskatchewan depuis deux trois ans déjà
on savait que ces systèmes le nous nous
avait échoué et chou avec nos enfants
qui en fait qui qui passent nos enfants
nos jeunes passent carrément entre les
moments dire entre les filets et qu'on
les échoppes puis c'est dur parce que on
a beau être éduqué au mimbeau peut-être
faire partie de l'assemblée nationale an
certains connaître d'autres provinces ou
ty vraiment comme sur le terrain mais on
n'arrive pas sauver des vies encore je
sais ce qui dure en fait d'être sur le
terrain
battre activistes de base de se battre
de combattre pour faire instaurer de
justement un meilleur service mais il ya
encore dire comment on appelle son idée
et c'est sûr on échappe
les deux coqs nommé cd je les
connaissais posséder cost mais laraque
sont arrivés au canada
oui tu n'as fontaine à winnipeg en fait
il ya trois ans déjà aux quatre ans
c'est une jeune fille de 15 ans qui qui
qui avait fait une fugue qui avait pas
reçu les services adéquats en protection
de la jeunesse puis elles avaient été
placées en famille d'accueil elle avait
fui sa famille d'accueil puis la police
ne l'avait pas chercher puis en fait
elle disparut finalement pions le pot
chercher puis on la retrouve en fait on
retrouve son corps dans un sac de
poubelle dans la rigueur rouge à
winnipeg et en fait des années plus tard
on a retrouvé le mais le suspect on le
retrouvait selon l'arrêté tout ça mais
il n'y a pas été il a été acquitté en
fait d accusation de gand n'a pas de
preuves ou pas on sait pas il y avait
toutes les preuves y avait comme mes
amies au manitoba souvent on acquitte
les blancs on va le dire le de crimes
haineux ou de crime sexuel où des crimes
toutes sortes de façon tellement facile
et donc aux autochtones
mais j'ai surtout envers les autochtones
pile en cas de bug du gwada au manitoba
autochtone ouais même il ya un secteur
comme ailleurs il ya un quartier qu'on
appelle le north end c'est vraiment
comme un grand quartier de la ville qui
se trouve au nord mais je connais pas
trop l'histoire en détail du manitoba
mais je sais que à winnipeg il ya
plusieurs populations autochtones qui
ont été amenés à winnipeg même même et
c'est ce qui fait en sorte que
maintenant c'est une des plus grandes
populations urbaines autochtones au
canada une à winnipeg donc ses environs
de 40% de la population la ville est en
fête justement plusieurs problématiques
sociales se retrouve à winnipeg même
mais justement winnipeg c'est vraiment
un ring
le manitoba s'est plaint de communautés
partout je pense que la population est
vraiment beaucoup plus grande comparée à
ici par exemple saskatchewan
en alberta aussi de plus tu voir la
région plus sûre trop des communautés
plus que des villages de blanc ou de
canadiens en gros puis ils n'ont que
deux copains de bauchi ça s'est passé
j'essaye vraiment de peux me tromper son
alberta en saskatchewan
mais c'est un jeune un jeune homme qui a
eu le malheur de se retrouver proche du
terrain d'une ferme d'une famille
blanche et je sais plus trop qu'est ce
que s'est passé mais je pense à voiture
avait tombé en panne ou quelque chose
mais le lob label le père de famille est
sorti en passant que le jeune autochtone
voulaient lui voler quelque chose et il
le prit sa carabine pillot tiré dessus
une pile lui même ou s'il a été acquitté
par la suite mais comme quoi même
surtout en région mais même dans les
milieux urbains
les jeunes se retrouvent en danger les
populations autochtones se trouve se
retrouve en danger surtout par rapport à
des actes racistes on veut dire comment
donc c'est assez com comment dire voyons
comment
oui c'est ça arrive souvent et souvent
justement les personnes qui est qu'on
accuse de ces crimes là mais sont
acquittés ça doit être pour une
activiste comme toi c'est extrêmement
frustrant à toutes les fois puis comment
comment est-ce que tu reste optimiste
dans ce cas comment est-ce que tu
continues à 1 vouloir combattre ces
congolais avait avec tout ce qui touche
aux caries pas ce qui m'attend
attractive de façon durable c'est une
des choses les plus difficiles pour la
santé mentale entre autres le quand tu
vois que les choses avancent pas comme
tu aimerais qu avance puisque tu réussis
tu continues à s'impliquer autant
partons nord que par quelques parties
prise de parole pour ces enjeux l'appui
que tu vois que ça change pas de même
dans des cas comme ceux que tu es nommé
que trois ans plus tard on se retrouve
avec sensiblement le même système
défaillant
comment tu comment tu réussis à
continuer à à vouloir mener ce combat là
en fait
en fait c'est aussi parce que on arrive
à montréal il ya huit ans j'ai voulu
rejoindre non seulement le mouvement et
donne au moins ici qui commence et était
l'une des rares places au québec où on
pouvait avoir une manif devant moi je le
lac au nord avec des dix autochtone
activistes où six militants ou qui font
simplement qu'ils descendent dans la rue
parce que à ce moment là je voulais
vraiment faire partie d'un mouvement
j'avais l'impression qu'on avait ce
besoin là de sortir d'une certaine
léthargie puis à ce moment là aussi à 8
ans je comprenais à peine 12 venait
cette léthargie là mais quand j'ai vu
les populations se soulever au pays je
me suis dit je veux faire partie de
cette si je peux je veux y contribuer
donc je suis arrivé ici est en fait ici
j'ai rencontré plusieurs femmes cnn que
j'admire beaucoup c'est ellen gabriel
qui a été la porte à rodez mon rap
pendant la crise donc surtout à une
époque où je pense que les femmes ont
les ans on les écoutait pas beaucoup
quand elle prenait la parole donc
c'était assez déjà commandé fort je
faisais pas d'autres non mais les femmes
en général puis probablement encore plus
les femmes autochtones
oui exact c'est ça dont on est dans une
crise aussi importante que celle que la
crise d'oka aussi je trouve ça assez
pour moi c'est une prouesse c'est
d'avoir osé quand même justement assumer
sa tradition de dire nous c'est une
femme qui parle et ellen gabriel a fait
partie donc de toutes les luttes depuis
1990 puis j'imagine qu'il avait déjà
commencé à militer un peu avant mais à
ce moment le sait c'est une personne qui
donc si on se dit l'officiel hm
commençant 90 ça fait 30 ans mais elle
est encore sur les fronts elle est
encore en train de donner des
conférences d'éduquer les gens en qui je
trouve ça vraiment admirable puis même à
elle je poserai la question c'est
comment tu fais en même temps en fait je
pense que chez nous c'est raide il ya la
différence que surtout quand on est
activiste on est rapidement entouré de
gens qui sont dans la tradition qui
tente de revitaliser les cérémonies de
transmettre les enseignements anciens
s'épiler les plus récents mais aussi de
toujours avoir une bonne réflexion
consciente clair sur qu'est ce qui se
passe et il ya toujours une explication
à qui ce qui se passe
puis il ya toujours une raison de
continuer donc en quelque sorte et en
même temps c'est sûr que justement
comparé à ces personnes je les appelle
souvent mes prédécesseurs toutes ces
femmes le qui quittent ces pionnières
des luttes qui sont passés avant moi
avons-nous de ma génération mais je me
dis si elles ont été capables de le
fable de continuer à le faire
moi je capable quand même temps je me
dis c'est sûr que mentalement
émotionnellement c'est très dur
rien depuis depuis des années pour moi
c'est il ya des vagues de deux pas de
désespoir mais des fois oui oui c'est ça
c'est quand même assez cyclique donc je
me dis ok c'est quand même normal pied
sur une vague que je passe par-dessus
pied dans la prochaine cerveau tu es
dans le creux ça va bien aller puis
quand la vague va arriver je sais d'où
je cours je comprends comment que ça se
passe bien en temps je me dis en ce
moment quand tout devient tout semble
impossible mais moi j'ai quelqu'un qui
ait jamais cru que l'impossible est
totalement impossible donc moi pour moi
dans ma vie même l'impossible est
possible mais des fois quand toute la
toux adler impossible politiquement
parlant vie socialement parlant
puis ma compréhension de qu'est ce qui
se passe en amérique du nord
ces jeux j'étudie je continue je
continue à lire je continue à lire d d d
d analyse des gens d'ailleurs des gens
de des écrivains d'autres des ratures
qui comprennent aussi la colonisation de
leur pays puis comment est-ce que leur
leurs militants à eux continuent de
mener leur combat donc je me dis c'est
pas juste nous ici qui sommes les seuls
sons et paul est seul au monde à
combattre à faire ce travail-là puis je
pense même qu'on lit qu on le fait
ensemble même si on n'est pas connecté
mais tout se met en fête à à garder je
pense une certaine sérénité d'esprit
mais aussi j'ai plus à rome moi je fais
beaucoup d'écoles j'ai beaucoup de
conférences je rencontre les jeunes chez
des ateliers d'écriture
et d'année en année en fait les
questions que les jeunes me pose son
deviennent de plus en plus éclairés très
intelligent tu ne dis pas qu'ils
l'étaient pas avant mais je dois très
éduquée très instruits se poser question
ils nous posent des questions ils
veulent en savoir plus
il veut comprendre en amont pied en fond
les questions autochtones qu'il est
question aussi de sociétés de la société
dans laquelle ils se trouvent
donc moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
vraiment la prochaine génération qui
vaut vraiment je pense créer un espèce
de tournant dans la société
je pensais ce qu'ils ont comme entre
peut-être 10 ans et 20 ans ce moment
qu'ils sont en train d'arriver aux
tensions du marché du travail autant sur
la place publique sur les réseaux
sociaux dès jeudi
on y voit de plus en plus prendre la
parole sur les réseaux puis je pense que
justement les réseaux sociaux deviennent
là la force de cette génération là donc
j'ai l'impression pour moi que notre
avenir est vraiment entre leurs mains et
je me dis mon rôle à moi c'est de mener
ce combat au quotidien mais aussi
d'aller chercher qu'est ce que je peux
donner au pkk est ce que je peux te
donner à ces générations le comme
l'information comme comme réponse à
leurs questionnements et du terrain tant
qu'écrivaine en tant qu'artiste je me
dis je peux contribuer un peu à en amont
à ce que eux devront faire comme
changement est ce que tu vois cette
génération l'arrivée avec l'optimisme du
changement est-ce que autant tu vois une
génération au dessus ou est ce que le
racisme it est profondément ancrée ou
est-ce que tu dises ça changera pas par
en haut ça va changer vraiment plus par
un bon team par exemple les justes les
deux infirmières dans la vidéo du
meurtre de joyce en fait toute cette
génération là où est ce que tu dis le
racisme semble tellement loin tellement
profond qu on dirait que on dirait que
l'idée de se battre pour que ça change
apparaît comme insurmontable alors que
passer par l'autre côté
par les jeunes c'est beaucoup plus
réaliste j'ai l'impression c'est pour
répondre en partie à tâtons à ta
question c'est réaliste en quelque sorte
dans le sens que les jeunes sont en
train de tout absorbé en ce moment c'est
donc si on leur donne ce qu'on voudrait
leur donner de bons positif éclairé vont
prendre que ça vaut les influencer d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est même si
leurs parents restent des fois c'est pas
toutes les familles mais si leurs
parents restés racistes ils vont pas
nécessairement le devenir mais parce
qu'ils vont recevoir d'autres
informations de côté puis eux-mêmes vont
faire cette réflexion est à mener sa
exact je pense que c'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment un peu partout poussent et
les réseaux sociaux fait en sorte que
les pays sont connectés les
questionnements sont connectés c'est le
gros exemple que j'ai c'est que tik tok
par exemple sert beaucoup de d'outils de
sensibilisation entre communautés donc
les jeunes entre eux cc du kke en fait
et ce pan de ces questions le ce sur les
internets donc on n'est même pas au
courant à quel point ils ont ces
réflexions l'appui ils sont rendus dans
la réflexion mais souvent justement je
me dis cette génération là c'est sûr que
c'est plutôt du site ces femmes-là ces
infirmières le j'ai l'impression que ce
qui aurait peut-être aucun moyen de
retour t il c'est peut-être un point de
non-retour d'aller jusqu'à justement
d'être un être humain puis d'être
infirmière
si je me pose ces questions le à quel
point est ce que tu es rendu n'entend on
tombe background dans ta vie pour que la
personne qui est couché le devant toi
que tu es censé soigner des terrans du
hunan en entendant ton évolution pour
croire que tu vas juste comme lui donner
ce que tu penses qui est bon pour elle
puis cinq puis ça va pas la tuer ou
qu'elles mêmes têtes a senti la volonté
de de mettre fin à la vie de cette
personne native
dit comment est ce que c'est possible
encore aujourd'hui mais les la vidéo le
montre pidjot est en fait je je je n'ai
pas tout regardé la vidéo j'ai juste
regardé débris parce que tu vois capable
qui est je me dis j'essaie de rentrer
dans sa tête qui au delà de la peur
fidèles du désespoir puis de de sentir
comme je veux tu mourir ici était au
delà de ça j'ai l'impression qu'elle a
eu tort
un éclaircissement d'esprit elle a pris
son téléphone elle a ouvert son facebook
elle a ouvert la vidéo en direct pied
c'est comme si la dernière volonté ou
dans ses dernières volontés c'était je
veux vous montrer c'est quoi ces jeux
vous montrer la vérité que ça se passe
pour vrai puis j'espère que vous allez
faire quelque chose avec ça donc c'est
vraiment ce feeling que j'ai puis je me
dis bon c'est jusqu'ici je voulais me
concentrer sur la création de en étant
pandémie donc on essaie me confiner
indépendamment du moment de l'année je
me dis je me rends questionner moi je
sais comme comment est ce que je fais
pour revenir en création mais de quoi je
veux parler est ce que je veux parler de
soucis chez beaucoup en questionnement
est en fait d'un coup il ya comme cette
voie là qui surgit du jour au lendemain
qui dit fait quelque chose c'est le zim
et j'ai toute la vie même m'a amenée sur
ce chemin là mais je suis vraiment
chanceux j'ai une carrière maintenant
que je peux appeler carrière justement
j'ai un travail j'ai dit oui je
travaille en autonomie d'un travail puis
j'ai tout ce qui me vient un pij et de
la reconnaissance aussi et puis j'ai
passé plusieurs fois ça fait huit ans
que j'écris ce fait en fait neuf ans que
j'ai commencé à écrire c'est déjà comme
une grande partie de ma vie et j'arrive
à g29 j'arrive à 29 puis j'ai tout ça
donc je suis chanceuse sait si c'est
comme si elle quand il me parle elle m'a
dit fais quelque chose avec ce puis je
me dis moi je suis allé à joliette
devant l'hôpital le lendemain quand il y
avait le la vigile du loin et là je me
suis dit il faut que je promets de fuji
promed que je vais me battre jusqu'à la
fin pour qu'on puisse faire reconnaître
le racisme systémique pour que sa vie ne
soit pas en vain son dernier geste
elle ne l'est pas fait en vain et je me
dis j'arrive à ce moment là dans ma vie
mais aussi dans la société dans la
transition convient je pense là on
transite de monde un nom d'une
impression de deux structures un an je
sais pas mais j'ai l'impression qu'on me
définissent image une période très
exactement jusqu'à non plus mais je me
dis on est vraiment et au milieu le
petit elle est là peut-être justement la
force de faire change de faire basculer
ces choses-là tipis et elle nous parle
de thé vainqueur je me dis donc là où
j'en suis dans ma vie j'ai le rôle et la
responsabilité de porter cette voie là
et de répondre à ce qu'elle veut de nous
tes et donc tout d'un coup ça comme
rechuté mais mes questionnements puis
comme elle à s'éclater je sais c'est que
sociaux mais comme tu dis c'est
tellement je reviens sur un élément est
à mentionner typo cannes être humain
soit devant toi qui t'es même pas si on
sentait pas une once d'empathie le thé
pour la douleur car sans tpiy est un cri
qui était ça démontre à quel point
justement il ya une déconnexion noter
entre des humains entre entre que la
personne soit différente quand même pas
tant cette espèce de deux unités de base
qui fait qu'ils étaient les pulsions qui
dit qu'il faut que j'arrête personnes
l'autre c'est que c'est vraiment en
crise on ne sommes ni vraiment attristé
pis puis justement les réseaux sociaux
c'est quand même spécial que c'est ce
que ça prenne pour que aujourd'hui
justement les jeunes c'est du petit
parce qu'il était on en a parlé tous
pour suivre le quelques mois maïté
saganash et podcasts épi est tellement
d'affaires qu'on en discute et qu'on
apprend peu comme un genou ne pas après
l'école je sais pas s'il s'est passé
programme a changé maintenant mes mots
justement plus appris sur le racisme sur
sur l'histoire dans les dernières années
à travers le réseau
derniers mois à travers mes recherches
personnelles pili ps qui ne sont lancés
ces réseaux sociaux que dans mon
parcours scolaire
quand même c'est quand même fou tipi
j'ai l'impression pas mal les jeunes
sont plus éveillés parlement c'est ce
qu'ils disent la cause de ce type i pis
qu'elles aient ouvert son téléphone
c'est une tragédie absolue jusqu'à son
décès qui a découvert son téléphone
justement c'est ça ça a tout changé en
fait à fès à faire en sorte que je
thomas a soit pas oublié mais combien il
y en eu c'est selon comme incarne le
khimar anonymat comme se piquant quand
t'es con qu'on ne sait même pas qu'on en
parle même pas tout ceci ccc c'est
vraiment fou le tpiy depuis depuis des
siècles en fait le trou depuis est
depuis toujours ici finalement des
piquets fax et au jour de ces énoncés
vraiment c'est vraiment difficile seppi
puis je salue la force que j'espère je
te manquer qui aura un avant/après de
cet événement le thé comme c'est comme
et comme la mode georges floyd fait
blocage mardi un deuxième souffle puis
qu'on en a parlé puis qu'est vraiment eu
des des changements pour l'espagne
continuera dans la voie des piges je me
suis calmé et étaient venus aussi on
était en plein dedans je te disais c'est
cesser ces merveilleuses qui se passe on
entend que tu es le mouvement platel
d'arreter mais il faut il faut que
fauqué un mouvement il faut qu'on parle
des autochtones de plus le tpiy il y en
a un qui le met lorsque 6,6 peut avoir
une bonne chose à soi que ça allume un
feu lutte c'est qui qui qui brûle pour
longtemps et un camp quand c'est quand
ça arrive et qu'on se dit à qui le
utilisons cette petite marque de force
extrême pour faire un changement piqué
là
le mouv du gouvernement c'est de
destituer la ministre aux affaires
autochtones puis de la remplacer par un
homme blanc sans consulter personne
personne aucun membre la communauté
semble qu'ils enquêtaient queniez
racisme systémique longtemps encore du
service policier de la ville de montréal
le profilage racial
à défaut de meilleur mot c'est d'école
classe et d'école ce qui comprend pas
comment quelqu'un peut penser que
c'était un move et des gens qui sait que
ça ne changeait de tricks a laissé
quasiment je me dis c'est que je m'en
excuse mais la france qu'ils m'en de
dire mis en eau par asus le sait fort
puis il ne peut plus on a mis un
policier donc on va gérer nos champs exo
parce que ce soit cas pas de vous tenir
c'est ça le message qu'ils envoient
parmi tous les autres c'est c'est aussi
vouloir comme il ya le terme pour la i
sing c'est vraiment aussi comme je suis
pas comment dire mais c'est s'essayer il
ya quand même là je sais pas comment
dire j'arrive pas à le dire j'ai le mans
criminalisation dans ce sens que c'est
comme si ce qu'il faudrait criminaliser
ce serait les actes nm piles et les
actes racistes mais en fait c'est comme
si on voulait nous dire qui a un fils
que ce soit nous qui soirée ont
criminalisé simplement pour descendre
dans les rues pour nommer le problème
aussi puis pour faire pression pour que
le racisme est systémique soient nos
métiers c'est fou parce que juste avant
que que françois legault face le
changement de d'amour à la première on
avait l'impression était sur le point
d'y faire dire qui est du racisme
technique parce que même geneviève
guilbaud à tout le monde en parle a
donné la définition même du racisme
systémique mais si vous êtes toujours
les modalités à les inverser constamment
même en ayant constant watch isabelle
picore et michèle audette devant et oui
c'est ça
donc encore l'homme je me posais des
questions comme ça tu sais où est ce que
tu en es dans ta vie pour arriver comme
a continué à mentir de même dans la face
des gens et devant george pipas 2
millions de téléspectateurs
c'est là qu'on a vu à quel point c'est
la ligne du parti
parce que décrivait le racisme système
et c'est qui ça noté elle découvre l
aspect dire dans le blanc des yeux soyez
audacieux puis oser le dire pis à dix
les racismes piété aviez perdu une année
marquée par tout sauf que de dire le mot
systémique
ça fait que au lieu que la
responsabilité soit sur les individus
veiller sur nous avons pu
ils veulent parce que c'est la seule
raison dans le fond un petit moment
qu'il dit tu fasses quelque chose peut
pas juste dire aux gens arrêtez d'être
raciste vous que changent les systèmes
en place pour régler les problèmes qui
se sont pas préparés
mais exactement quoi c'était quoi cinq
jours après tout le monde en parle il ya
eu le changement pour l'afro niable tout
de suite le lendemain la première chose
que ian lafrenière a fait c'est de dire
qu'il ne reconnaît pas le racisme
systémique et qu'il n'existe pas c'est
donc tout d'un coup il ya ce changement
là à 180 degrés ou on est complètement
justement mais ça m'aurait dit plus haut
les nominés flabbergasting pas ce qu'il
s'est passé dit comme comme vous dites
c'est du jour au lendemain on n'a pas
été consulté il ya personne qui était au
courant qu'ils allaient faire ce
changement lot et donc c'est vraiment
comme si c'est vraiment comme je suis
remonté mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
même pas un faux paul tracy s'est
carrément des silences une décision
consciente avec un message clair
exact c'est pas comment on amuse gueule
parce qu'il était comme qualifiés puis
c'est quand on a pris la décision
d'envoyer ce message là si si c'est
débile
monsieur nick 1,4 toutes ces nouvelles
sont tombées en fait dans l'enchaînement
des événements que ça ça arrive puisque
mottet évidemment je suivais son mandat
après que toi mais quand ça nous est
arrivé c'était incompréhensible
incompréhensible en plus de changer de
ministres femmes pour un ministre encore
ici quand même voici
voici un cabinet paritaire pulsé comme
on va les enlever tranquillement une à
une pour mettre des hommes qui ont la
même pensée entre que pas trop
s'éterniser sur ça parce que c'est
incompréhensible rien il ya comme rien a
expliqué on dirait mais en fait il ya eu
il ya toute une analyse qu'on peut en
retirer dans le fond parce que depuis là
depuis la vidéo en direct de joyce des
jeux dans cette vidéo
dans cette vidéo là on retrouve tous les
stéréotypes
non non non dans une seule phrase une
phrase on veut exempter et donc c'est
comme wow c'est pas c'est pas juste
tellement c'est même pas hasardeuse tjs
pas pour comment expliquer sa démarche
comme
pourquoi est ce que on a tous les
stéréotypes dans la même phrase est émis
par la même personne et qu'on voit ceux
d'entre eux dans une vidéo sur facebook
si cela veut dire plein de choses autant
ces stéréotypes là où ses idées la ccc
perception le de la population
autochtone sont encore assez tangible
dans la population donc ça ça démontre
que ça existe encore même si on a
l'impression où on veut se rassurer puis
dire non on est ouvert on est comme on
est communautaire on est on partage
entre les cultures qu'on a du mal à
assabou et les comportements racistes et
les comportements de ce que j'appelle
mon de colonisateurs qui perdure depuis
des ddd siècle justement de génération
en génération qui ont un point où on est
rendu tellement inconscient ce
comportement le 2 on les reproduit sans
savoir qui justement on
on creuse tout le temps les inégalités
simplement parce qu'on reproduit ces
comportements le dit autant du côté de
ceux qui sont issus des colonisateurs
reproduit ce comportement l'otan de ceux
qui sont issus des colonisés en temps
peuvent avoir tendance à reproduire le
comportement colonisé non il ya toujours
ces relations leur qui ne sont jamais
réellement équilibrée ces rapports de
force invisible dont on n'est pas
conscient parce que justement on n'est
pas éduqué donc tout ce qui arrive en ce
moment même ce qui s'est passé avec
geneviève guilbault puis ce qui s'est
passé justement jusqu'à ian lafrenière
c'était juste dans ses nominations là on
revient en fait à une relation que nous
acteurs colonisés ou le gouvernement
legault finalement éclairci sa ligne
directrice de partie mais aussi sa sa
position il voulait tout faire comme
s'il n'était pas dans cette direction le
mais finalement tout ça s'éclaircit dans
ce sens que mettre un ex-policier un
ancien militaire de cesser recréer le
narratif des pensionnaires du trot mode
kidnapping des enfants dans les
communautés alors que justement le
québec ne veut pas être le canada et
voudrait peut-être même si encore
aujourd'hui se sortir du canada
on voit les anglais comme si si c'est
leur faute c'est tout autre concept sun
annonce que nous aurons un blanc mais
ici même on reproduit ces choses là de
façon tellement comme c'est même pas
comme je peux fait exprès si c'est même
tellement conscient presque simplement
parce qu'on ne veut pas avouer que le
racisme systémique existe et finalement
on recrée tellement de choses et c'est
la nomination de yann la première c'est
aussi moi je les crises ma page facebook
parce que pour moi c'était trop classe
et comme c'est une âme nanciers
policiers mais tu viens dire aux femmes
autochtone de val-d'or qui ont dénoncé
leurs agresseurs qui sont tous des
policiers que que c'est pas les
policiers qui vous ont agressé c'est
sûrement je sais pas qui d'autre mais
c'est sûrement pas eu parce qu'on a
tenté même de l'est les acquittés
étaient et même si tout ça c'est même
pas réglé ces femmes ne l ont été en
danger par la suite elle devait fuir de
ville en ville pour pas se faire jeter
de deux noms dans les rues ou pour ne
pas se faire regarder croche dans dents
enlève dans les villes en abitibi elles
ont dû un temps se cacher pour pouvoir
se sentir en sécurité mais même là elle
se sentait pas en sécurité parce que
justement tous les yeux étaient braqués
sur ces fameux qui ont dénoncé les
policiers de la sq eu je pense pied et
donc ça ramène toutes sortes de choses
tout ce qui se passe à partir de joyce
jusqu'à la nomination de ian lafrenière
non c'est pas la suite mais tout se
révèle
où en est la société québécoise à
l'intérieur de la société canadienne qui
est justement à ces conversations leur
pisse à ce tir de bord en bas mais ici
on veut comme poser si ces conversations
l'appui on n'y arrive pas parce que les
gens ont peur de dire qu'ils sont
racistes mais c'est même pas une
question d'être raciste ou pas c'est
simplement d'avouer qu'on est ignorant
que justement oh c'est pas juste parce
qu'on ignorant parce qu'on ignorant
parce qu'on est con on le sait vraiment
juste parce que le système d'éducation
ou ci a échoué ça fait des années qu'on
sait il se fait des années qu'on sait
que les professeurs eux-mêmes paye le
matériel scolaire de leurs élèves
les les enseignants partout québec se
battre pour se faire entendre par
rapport à soi même sous jean charest on
en parlait déjà de là à quel point les
écoles au québec est en train de de
tomber en ruine c'est donc cc66 on sait
quel point aussi les services de santé
et y échoue à plusieurs endroit pas
juste par rapport aux racistes
systémique ou sur les populations
vulnérables aux assises et c'est partout
au tcc aussi les services sociaux c'est
la dpj donc moi j'ai l'impression que la
plupart des services publics sont ils
ont complètement été abandonné par les
gouvernements la cac continue aussi de
ne pas aller régler ces problèmes là et
on se retrouve en fait avec une
population wiki ignorante donc il n'a
pas les outils pour comprendre les les
effets du racisme systémique
elle n'a pas les outils pour pouvoir l'a
nommé et ne pas non plus personne dans
le gouvernement qui souhaite comme faire
en sorte que la population
ces séductrices donc si on doit le faire
nous même dans certains cas justement
qui nous ont des maisons - lacie si
j'essaie autant de choses sur ma culture
puis sur les autres cultures d'automne
c'est juste à cause des réseaux sociaux
c
d'autres je suis même pas là l'école
depuis genre 2011 justement parce que
2012 parce que je retrouve pas ce que je
cherche dans les institutions scolaires
c'est donc cesser ça veut tout et un
petit jeune autiste donc c'est je me dis
c'est pas juste nous c'est je pense que
je pense que les les tous ceux qui
militent justement pour que ces
problèmes-là soient réglés et puis qu'on
les assume depuis qu'on aille chercher
les solutions concrètes si je pense
qu'un jour moi je sais à ce chat arriver
aujourd'hui comme conclusion ce matin
vraiment faut vraiment qu'on convergent
nos forces nos voix puis de dire mais en
fait on sait c'est quoi les
problématiques on sait c'est quoi les
problèmes et maintenant ça amène à ce
que des gens meurent sur leur lit
d'hôpital à ce que des enfants soient
assassinés par leurs parents parce que
ses parents le lion s'est jamais trouvée
laide qui cherchait de l'aide
psychologique dont ils avaient besoin
these ccc c'est tout d'aider des choses
qui sont interreliés finalement il faut
les éclaircir il faut les sortir de
l'ombre qui se dit mais c'est ce qu'on a
sur la tempe puis faut faire quelque
chose c'est parce que en même temps tout
tout est interrelié on peut avoir
l'impression que le travail est long à
faire mais en fait si on commence
simplement par exemple justement
reconnaître leurs aspects systémiques
non s'attaque aussi à tout des pratiques
qui ne devrait pas être dans ses
systèmes le thé comme la pandémie en
révéler comme elles se compteraient de
lésigny dans les ch et celle des mais
c'est la même chose
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable d'aller
fouiller la dame de dire qu'il ya
réellement un problème et c'est quoi ce
problème là c'est peut-être un problème
d'éducation justement donc on revient
tout on fait toujours comme le tour de
110 ans mais c'est ce qui se passe tu
parles du de l'échec du système
d'éducation une des affaires qui a été
dit à tout le monde en parle
la semaine dernière c'était que possible
en que la piste de solution commence par
une réécriture de l'histoire
maintenant c'est qu'on se dise à qui
l'on va rythme en parler puis on va le
faire
puis est ce que tu penses que ce c'est
une bonne piste de début de solution de
faire re écrivons l'histoire pour mieux
comprendre
la relation entre les personnes entre
les peuples mieux comprendre tout ce qui
nous intéresse connecte tout ce qui nous
différencie pipi apprenons là dessus
qu'ils font fonds dont une base qui pas
écrite par d'un point de vue que nous
avons une vue colonisateur mais qui est
écrit de façon neutre sur toutes ses
copines ou comme un coin du zinc surtout
en arrêtant de se mettre la tête dans
l'absolu l'imam ali les prix sont les
moins glorieuses de l'histoire
je pense que je pense que beaucoup seul
je pense que c'est puis encore une fois
tu en avais parlé mais il a été médecin
ce conte ce conte ce qu'on nous apprend
finalement ue à l'école c'est l'histoire
deux tonnes préconisations pis
colonisation puis ensuite grand vide
puis crise d'oka puis c'est pas mal ce
depuis la crise d'oka c'est les
autochtones sont soit des méchantes
succès fac et il ya vraiment un vide
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'en tant
que société on et on a un grand malaise
avec les pensionnaires avec beaucoup
avec la loi sur les indiens avec
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui font
qu'on sens la facture qu'est ce que
j'imagine que on est encore là dessus
bcc c'est sûr que oui mais pour moi
c'est une parmi toutes les solutions je
pense pas que ce soit la seule et la
première mais elle fait partie des des
premiers gestes à faire c'est justement
réécrire cette histoire le commune au
québec
parce que celle du québec est assez
spécifique bien longtemps je me disais
c'est quand même ici que par où la
colonisation commencé et inondant du
côté nord
donc comment est ce qu'on fait pour
reconnaître aussi et assumer cette
histoire leurs deux premières colonies
et et comment on s'est dit que pour
comprendre les conséquences cette
colonie n'a jusqu'ici parce qu'il ya
aussi toute l'histoire de l'exclavage
qu'il faut ajouter un tout là toute la
donne
l'esclavagé des noirs mais aussi des
autochtones y en a eu beaucoup donc
qu'ils sont les descendants de ces
esclaves autochtone
moi je me posais la question aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui pourrait dire de de cette
ascendance l'homme d'avoir soi comme
héritage familial tc donc si je me dis
et après qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il ya eu
je pense que toute l'histoire
par exemple juste l'histoire i nom et
est intrinsèquement liée à celle
d'hydro-québec t et quand j'apprends les
luttes par exemple se sont passés un peu
plus au nord au labrador menée par une
femme entre autres qui s'appelle
elisabeth pena chouikh même à 85 ans
aujourd'hui et continue parcourir le
territoire de façon traditionnelle
je me dis il ya il ya des mêmes j'ai
l'impression que du côté est d'aider
hinault on en connaît pas sinon plus
notre propre histoire de résistance donc
j'ai l'impression que chaque peuple
au québec aussi une histoire de
résistance qui devraient faire partie de
l'histoire du québec
kiki ans qui en l histoire du québec
mais qui devrait faire partie des livres
aussi donc c'est sûr il faut tout
réécrire se pisser dans ce sens que mon
camp je me rappelle de quand je me
souviens de mon cours d'histoire en
secondaire iv c'est j'ai trouvé ce jeu
quand j'y repense aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que c'est vide de
finalement tu y es juste oui des grands
sauts il ya des grands événements mais
qu'est ce que ça veut réellement dire
pour l'identité qui paie quoi stimuler
les questions que je me pose pas ce que
par exemple pour nous ce qui est ce qui
ce qui remplit nos identités j'ai
l'impression ce qu'il définit nos
identités en quelque sorte c'est tous
les combats que nos ancêtres ont mené
des générations génération pour qu'on
soit encore le puits conçois qu'on ait
la chance de dire que moi j'ai la chance
je suis nous et non québécois c'est je
suis inouïe au québec mais c'était toi
là avant il s'appelait on l'appelle
maintenant de simone parce qu'on est
dans des rapports de force mais avant
c'était le nom de chemin de l'intérieur
d'états donc c est comment est ce que je
me réapproprie mon propre narratif pour
être capable de le raconter et et qu'un
jour justement les chaque peuple qui se
trouve maintenant ici on puisse
justement faire converger nos récits
pinon narratif puis comment est ce qu'on
trouve un narratif commun pour dire
voici l'histoire du québec
et voici c'est de la façon dont elles
dont elle rempli mon identité puis c'est
sûr que avec ses six récits lot commun
tout le monde gagnerait au sens sujet
jean et j'écoutais une conférence que tu
as fait la poétique de la relation
territoire puis juste ce concept là par
exemple la relation aux territoires par
les autochtones à quel point est ce que
ça changerait complètement notre
perception du monde dans lequel on vit
puis en ce moment on peut le voir
facilement avec avec la crise climatique
qui s'en vient pour notre société de
consommation pile le non respect de la
terre de l'air de l'eau des animaux et
tout c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
grandement gagné tu es avec a juste
retourner à ce concept low du moins en
est consciente et de savoir que c'est
pas cette note vision la vision
nord-américaine de capitalisme qu'il si
loin d'être la vision unique puis même
qu en ce moment on serait beaucoup mieux
de retourner vers le territoire du fait
que je pense qu'on gagnerait à ses
récits comme un bleu absolu en pis si je
l' ai toujours pensé parce que j'ai
toujours vu j'ai eu la chance de voyager
beaucoup un peu partout dans le monde
qui le sait la poésie qui maintenant
voyager si je n'avais pas écrit des
livres je fais peut-être pas autant
voyager parce que c'est jeudi à la
plupart des voyages les époux pays que
j'ai pas payer mes billets d'avion c'est
j'ai été invité dans des festivals j'ai
été vite et dans l'est
des événements qui veulent se poser ces
questions là justement chi chi chi chi
aussi par la poésie pose des
questionnements assez importante de ces
et la poésie ont permis ces dialogues là
donc je dis souvent je suis profondément
peau est d'abord et avant tout parce que
justement c'est je dois tout à la poésie
quand même temps quand je cherche dans
notre passé dans nos traditions mais
notre pensée est fondamentalement
politique donc notre vision de notre
relation territoire est fondamentale
ford a mentalement politique et je me
dis comment est ce qu'on fait pour
rapatrier cette politique là était
comment est ce qu'on fait pour l'art est
appliquée dans nos vies team aussi un
questionnement je me pose tout les jours
vous allez finir par vous être toutes
les questions mais justement c'est quand
est ce que tu veux pour l'appliquer
était est aussi c'est pas juste la
relation territoire c'est la relation
aux autres ceux ci c'est moi si je
prends cette politique la relation
territoire à partir de la potée de la
relation d'edouard glissant qui lui pour
ces questions là quelles sont les
relations entre les cultures en donnant
comme exemple les antilles qui sont
issus de la colonisation mais qui sont
aussi issus de résistance ty de deux
peuples singulier qui en se mélangeant
sont devenus les peuples qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et inondant dans les pays
des antilles
donc ce qu'il appelle l'archipel isation
de ccc à ces rencontres le kick x qui
sont provoquées mais de ces rencontres
l'homme un souci d'aider littérature
complètement rejetés et en fait
justement je me disais comment est ce
que nous on peut être en relation avec
celui qui se posent encore comme
colonisateur ce peuple lacunes qui est
en domination sur le territoire
comment est ce qu'on fait pour être en
relation et le territoire quand il ya
tant de choses qui nous empêche de
l'être mais comment est ce qu'on fait
pour être en relation avec celui qui se
pose comme les colonisateurs et il
continuer à être soi-même t mais un
étang en grèce se vend toujours des dd
j'ai pas comment expliquer mini
tentative de créolisation sur soi c'est
ce que je veux c'est l'image que
j'aimais
c'est si je me dis qu'est ce qu'on est
capable de créer nous si on arrive
justement si du quai sur ces
comportements le comme je vous disais
plus tôt pis si on arrive à les
désamorcer ces comportements le à quel
moment et ce qu'on entre justement dans
le respect de la parole de l'autre celui
qui a été dominée il y à quel moment est
ce qu'on arrive à une égalité des
chances d'aider mais aussi des prises de
parole puis deux à quel moment est ce
qu'on arrive à l'écouté et puis encore
là souvent on va me sortir le mot
réconciliation n'est même pas rendus là
encore dans ce sens qu'il y à tout quand
j'observe ce qui se passe du côté des
peuples surtout qu'ils ont été qui ont
été colonisés je me dis il ya cette
première étape de deux risers de
s'élever malgré les les tentatives de ce
fait rabrouer disent faire rabaisser
cessé de s'élever puis de se redonner de
la fierté de la confiance et c'est ce
qu'on va appeler l'autodétermination la
réaffirmation ça va passer par la
réaffirmation identitaire dit mais
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
reconstruire nos identités
cl ont été pillés et est donc c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller chercher pour
reconstruire et faire quelque chose à
partir de ce compte du peu comptes qui
nous qui nous reste c'est et célèbre les
artistes pour moi entre en ligne de
compte parce que de ce qu'il nous reste
on est capable de créer beaucoup plus et
ça c'est la définition même en quelque
sorte de la résilience est d'être
capable à partir du négatif de créer du
positif mais j'ai l'impression cissé de
si peu mais sitôt la force de la
création tu es capable d'en faire plus
et pour moi c'est aussi ça la poétique
de la relation cc c'est quand tu es en
relation de les choses autour de toi
c'est la poésie c'est de savoir créer
quelque chose à partir de caisse qui
tantôt donc cesser si je me dis si on
est ce concept le con con con con oeuvre
c'est combien d'autres du passé on peut
ramener puisse dire que ce qu'elles
peuvent être des réponses aux crises
aujourd'hui et moi moi je suis convaincu
que tout ce qu'on a comme enseignement
anciens sont déjà des réponses aux
crises convient pardon
montez donc les crises du vivre ensemble
de la relation à l'autre mais aussi de
l'environnement départ par la
consommation aussi c'est moi je vois la
consommation maintenant comme comme un
symptôme de dépendance ou de
déséquilibre convient donc de quelles
sont les maladies mentales social qu'on
a mais bon individuellement mais
collectivement qui qui dit qu'on
entretient avec le matériel
mais tout ça c'est ce problème de
consommation vient qu'on a du fait qu'on
est on est à chercher des territoires
puis on se les approprier
donc la culture de l'appropriation et la
base même pour moi de toutes les
problématiques donc dans la culture
d'appropriation c'est le non respect de
l'autre si le pillage s'il elle c'est de
prendre à quelqu'un d'autre qui est
quelque chose qu'on lui envie peut-être
même de lui prendre quelque chose pour
le dominer donc pour moi ce que séquence
en philosophie c'est ce que moi
j'appelle le l'état de prédation cc on
est vraiment venu à un monde dans lequel
l'humain était il ya très longtemps dans
ce sens que on allait justement
rabaisser les moins forts pour aller
chercher de la force
non allez aussi je sais pas comment dire
si ce prendre je peux m'en demandait de
cesser de compris oui c'est ça de
s'approprier d'aller voler les autres à
les kidnapper les femmes si ça existait
ces choses là mais sté cccd fois dans
des moments de prédation seulement on
devient pour moi c'est un état pour moi
c'est un état primitif délai d'autres
prédation c'est de revenir à son état
premier d'être juste dans la survie dans
le besoin de combler ses besoins
primaires et dans la société de
consommation je vois un peu c'était tôt
leur revenir quand on consomme juste
pour combler nos besoins mais maintenant
même si on surconsomme pour combler le
vide qu'on ressent pas ce que la société
le monde où je sais pas l'humanité ne
n'est plus capable de nous combler
donc ces essais pour moi je vois ça
comme tout d'un schéma ou psychologiques
la bcc je vois quand même la source du
fait que depuis les premières
colonisations cessé il ya 500 ans et on
est dans les conséquences encore de ces
cons de sécurisation justement ce que tu
décris ces titres est barbare le
tristement cette maj l'aide d'un peu
plus guerrier qui pour conquérir un
autre peuple qui vous violer les femmes
qui voter qui voit piliers de ce puits
finalement ce site un schéma hausse des
comportements qui s'ils y arrivent
encore aujourd'hui mais d'une manière
civilisée du bonheur camouflet
finalement mais si les mêmes
comportements je me présente les mêmes
pulsions des bases humaine
les athlètes c'est qui qui sont encore
aussi présente aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment pitié je change de sujet mais à
une réflexion
cette semaine si je prends comme exemple
le côté des jeunes à l'école qui qui
décide de mettre des jupes des robes
d'été de déconstruire un peu les codes
2d ce moteur finalement de prendre un
peu la position d'allié à aux jeunes
filles de puiseaux des années finalement
c'était des revendications qui faisait
qu'ils trouvaient injuste pitt et je
pense que la réaction de la majorité des
chartes et d'applaudir cette initiative
clotilde était bon mais c'est le fun
d'avoir jeté des jeunes qui prennent qui
prennent la défense bead un groupe qui
est quand même finalement marginaliser
le thé andrew gemmell puis après ce qui
vient la réflexion puis la pression
beaucoup de ramener la critique c'est
quand même dommage que ça prenne des des
gens situation de privilèges pour
finalement que message son temps de
celui-ci
puis effectivement fait dommage parce
que justement le message est pas nouveau
mais j'ai quand même vraiment
l'impression que c'est triste à dire
mais c'est ce que ça prend
dans ce sens que ça prend les gens pour
son privilège pour dire quelque chose il
faut faire quelque chose pour que pour
que lisent les odeurs appartenant au
même groupe le écoute puis je pense que
je pense qu'il tient en général c'est
toujours être les les a pressés qu'ils
vont devoir arrêter de pression mais
c'est ça importe peu importe comment les
oppresseurs pardon si les oppresseurs
que mon devoir était de préciser parce
que même si les oppresser des arrêtés de
presser si ça passe passe
la décision doit être pris par les gens
en position de pouvoir de dodo pression
était justement telle image pour epa
depuis fortement de premier ministre et
de la personne avec les plus de pouvoirs
avec les plus des privilèges on veut ça
devrait devrait partir de l'oeuvre
d'allemands que si lui puis si son
gouvernement prendre position ça peut
juste avoir un effet domino t enfin pour
moi ça me rend pas dans la tête on
dirait la la position je me dis ce
serait tellement serait tellement
tellement des gens primé qui essaient de
faire entendre qu'ils essaient de ces
deux soirées coûte et changer les choses
qui suffirait qu'ils essayaient les
personnes à 60 prive l'agent 60 pouvoir
prenne position puis ça serait tellement
bénéfique exact malheureusement même si
on veut on voudrait pas que ce soit
comme ça mais si c'est comme ça mais
c'est sûr que j'ai fait que dans le code
et des jeunes garçons qui ont milité
pour les filles c'est on imagine aussi
dans le sens inverse il y fit avait
réussi à se faire entendre par les
médias sociaux on les aurait sûrement
très féministe de façon
péjoratif c'est donc il y aurait eu tout
alors que le sait les jeunes garçons qui
on les applaudit et puis on est bien
content et tout ce qui manque c'est ça
éclaire aussi notre état de nos
perceptions par rapport à qui et qui
fait quoi et en même temps j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi pendant des années sur ce en
fait justement de sk quel point en fait
des groupes de privilégier peuvent
prendre la parole pour les oppressés
j'ai vu qu'ils aient qui a délimité dans
ce sens que ça dépend de l'attitude de
ceux qui prennent la parole pour pour
les autres et c'est ce qui le font pour
recevoir une reconnaissance ou est-ce
qu'ils le font vraiment pour la bonne
cause c'est pour vraiment faire en sorte
que ces groupes là qui sont marginalisés
soit entendue donc dépendamment des
situations il faut toujours voir ce côté
là dessus et en est pour pour aller vers
quelqu'un qui relie deux en fait qui est
en position d'autorité
si c'est tellement plus et ça c'est
vraiment tellement plus complexe puis on
s'en rend compte en ce moment parce que
c'est justement l'on est on dirait qu'on
était sur le point de faire dire à
françois legault qui'il dirait
systémique parce qu'ils donnaient la
définition et on était vraiment sur le
banc il faisait juste renversé deux mots
en une phrase s'était fait le disait qu'
on était vraiment dans ce dans ses
impressions comme 170 anciens lequel on
est peut-être sur le point depuis juin
la main il ya ma première apparaît comme
la marche ou ça chauffe puis village me
dit imaginez si ces sommes sommes nous à
fait imaginer en fait ça nous là on a vu
le pire mais ça nous a fait imaginer ce
qui arriverait si françois legault
avouer qu'il est que ben pas avouer
c'est pas une question david avoué ou
potes c'est vraiment une question
fruit de dire que d'assumer que ça
existe ce pli que tout le monde a un
devoir d'éducation et donc le
gouvernement a le devoir et la
responsabilité de participer à cette
éducation le mais justement c'est cette
responsabilité-là finalement qui refuse
et qu'il n'y était en mettant justement
un policier et un ex policier et
militaire
ceci est en plus il s'enfonce encore
plus parce que justement on revient
comme je disais ou narratif des
pensionnats non convié même à une des
plus grandes aux pressions que les
autochtones envie qu on vécu mais je me
disais justement là où j'en suis rendu
c'est comme il faut vraiment j'ai
vraiment d une relation pas bourré mais
comme très difficile avec les la
politique parce que on en a vu des
politiciens se présenter puis promettre
tellement de choses pour ces causes
l'est mais d'arriver au pouvoir aider au
pouvoir et de sud à peine bouger sur ce
rapport à ça ou de vraiment faire les
choses pour que ça bouge c'est où on a
vu des politiciens promettre ça mais à
voir tous les obstacles possibles pour
pau y arriver et il sait ce dont il ya
vraiment comme ces difficultés là qui
met en même temps malheureusement c'est
quand même eux qui ont le pouvoir de
changer des systèmes puis des services
de d'instaurer d'ajuster des choses
c'est de changer justement dans le
système les structures d'aidé d'apporter
des vrais changements concrets donc
comme mais on n'a pas le choix tu sais
de quoi je parle
oui c'est ce qui depuis quand on est
rendu à parler au premier ministre est
directement moi j'ai jamais voulu
m'adresser à lui directement mélange
danse semaine j'avais pas le choix de
nommer hippie de le tagi et on est rendu
là on est proche le tpiy joyce et chaque
fois ne doit pas être là là là
super g en dix ans une victime parmi
tant d'autres ouaip et elle doit être la
dernière et on peut pas laisser passer
ce qui est arrivé et on connaître je
pense quand même beaucoup nos
responsabilités mais si justement le
gouvernement ne veut pas les assumer
comment est-ce qu'on va le faire c'est
si on al'impression justement que c'est
mal vu maintenant parce que lui ai dit
non tu parlais de l'or comme comme moyen
de rétablir la peau la balance mais de
rétablir ce dialogue puis tenez un
exemple tout à l'heure les les antilles
moi je te lis en martinique puis au
martinez qui avait un poète écrivain
aimé césaire qui viennent le puits lui
est ce que selon toi c'est un bon
exemple de en fait est ce que les
peuples antillais comme lamartine est
max ont une colonie française mais qui
ont résisté à au colonel colonialisme
parce que il a bossé encore ultra
gentillesse jusque le monde certaines
personnes parlent français la boutique
français de france qui est ce que selon
toi ce genre de modèle est un modèle de
colonisation qui qui a senti un succès
mais qui réussit ou qui a fonctionné
c'est quelque chose qui peut la
colonisation qui fonctionne c'est fou
parce que je vais jamais jusqu'à dire
que ça ça a fonctionné ou que ça ait
réussi mais en même temps dans certains
cas c'est sûr s'il aider les gens issus
des peuples colonisés ne croit même plus
en leurs propres cultures en leurs
propres valeurs qui en leur propre
peuple
en fait et souhaite plutôt s'identifier
de façon des fois très forte à la
culture dominante
je pense qu en quelque sorte oui mais je
pas capable de dire que ça est réussie
parce qu'il est toujours un moment où
c'est possible que la personne
souhaitant faire retrouver sa culture
d'origine depuis son peuple qui cesse
ses valeurs traditionnelles t et il ya
pour moi ya toujours ce danger là
justement que vu qu'on vit dans une
société qui dit qui est dominante t on
sort de la communauté on est dans le
québec tente et on est chez les blindés
ont cessé ce long terme nous ôter on
n'est pas chez nous soyons de chez nous
on n'est pas chez nous dès qu'on sort
n'a commenté mais maintenant la
communauté cessé de dire s'il ya
toujours le l'ombre du fédéral qui est
la pile l'histoire aussi qui derrière la
création des réserves qui qui qui hélas
tig est en dessous d'une sous nos pieds
si chaque personne je me sens de chaque
personne mais nantes dans chaque comté
il ya des gens qui veulent faire en
sorte que justement ce ne soient plus
considérés comme des réserves mais comme
des communautés ils veulent la
prospérité ils veulent faire en sorte
que des des services sont installés dans
leur communauté qui est du travail parce
que y'en a pas fait non il ya toutes
sortes d'initiatives comme ceux qui qui
qui qui me disent que on se sera pas
totalement réussi c'est simplement quand
on nous a tellement mis à terre que
c'est difficile pour nous de bouger puis
de faire bouger les choses mais
je pense c'est à ce moment là que je
crois vraiment que le collectif peut y
être pour beaucoup dans ces changements
le de façon très large mais il ya des
communautés qui l'ont fait de la petite
échelle qui ont réussi à se sortir un
peu de ce joug colonial tew colonialiste
qui ont réussi à rapatrier leurs
cultures d'aider des éléments du passé
qu'ils ont failli perdre qui ont été
perdus puis qu'ils ont réussi à avec
beaucoup de recherches à remettre
oui c'est ça au grand jour dit donc
faire en sorte aussi que leurs
populations se s'identifient à ces
éléments là c'est aussi un autre des
filles donc c'est comme c'est des fois
j'ai l'impression le monde sait ici des
programmes et sinon moi je me rappelle
quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai grandi dab
et qu'on monte dans la ville puis même
si mes parents sont innu moi mon frère
ma soeur on ne parlait plus la langue un
certain moment puis j'allais à l'école
je recevais juste la culture québécoise
juste la culture blanche t puis je me
posais pas de questions
c'est plutôt vers la fin de mon
secondaire où je me suis dit attends
est-ce que ce que ce qui a je suis
amérindienne tpiy puis moi si ce n'est
pas parce que je cherchais mon identité
initialement ça a commencé par un
questionnement pas comme pourquoi est-ce
qu'on me mets à part moi je voulais
comprendre pourquoi est-ce qu'on me mets
ta apport que j'essayais de me faire des
amis que j'ai essayé même des fois
dépendant des personnes ça ne traitait
pas être ami avec d'autres faits c'est
comme pourquoi tous appuyé monnaies
quand j'ai compris que c'est peut-être
parce que à l'époque je me dis
amérindiens parce que le terme que
j'avais tu sais je me suis dit si c'est
à cause de ça je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est à quoi ça sert à rien je me
rappelle m'être dit mais ces gens là je
les vois comme moi aussi je les vois mon
égal mais je ne me vois pas leur égal
c'est quoi ceci donc semé
questionnements ont commencé comme ça
j'avais 15 56
je ressentais un mal de vivre l'est
pourtant je me disais pourtant j'ai pas
vécu de choses graves dans ma vie mais
je sens un mal de vivre intense puis je
raconte souvent la première fois que
j'ai vu le film de jean dujardin à la
télé des années de sortir en 2007
environ 2008 des projets web piégé géant
bleu je pense que le monde entier mais
tombé j'ai senti le vide j'ai senti le
sol s'ouvrir son épi carrément secondes
ceux de nos nièces peau mais gégé j'ai
eu un choc pendant dix mois je m'en
rappelle plus je me dis si ce mal de
vivre le vient de là il vient pour
serment des gens autour de moi qui me
font du mal volontairement s'ils font
passer volontairement d'où ça vient ça
vient de là donc ça apporte tellement de
une réponse concrète à tous mes
questionnements ce moment le pij médicis
et se met à bien de le dire c'est bien
ça vient des pensionnats ça vient de la
loi sur les indiens la création des
réserves métier ils savaient pas les
individus qui me le font chaud au
quotidien de plus ancré plus profond
disant qu'il est les individus autant de
mois souffrent parce qu'il ya eu ça
avant tu es donc je me dis pied en même
temps en quelque sorte on me transmis ce
mal de vivre le s'était pas
nécessairement le mien est il maintenant
avec l'artiste la peinture la création
le théâtre est tout seul la poésie ça
m'a permis de comprendre aussi qu'une
partie de ce mal de vivre le ne vient
pas seulement des personnes qui me l'ont
directement transmis mais aussi même
dans ma famille quelle a été la première
rupture dans notre histoire c'est celle
avec le territoire donc on porte encore
cette rupture le site b sur lot ceux de
d'être séparé de notre mode de vie
c'est là c'est là je pensais le premier
traumatisme outils et de se faire
traiter comme si on était des moins que
rien c'est un autre trop mais on se dit
les pensionnats où les gens ont été
abusés
jusque dans leur intimité jusque dans
leurs cordes et de façon très violente
donc cesser on est héritier de ce et
j'ai en même temps c'est l'or qui m'a
permis de continuer à rechercher la
guérison de ses trop mal
puis de m'en sortir parce qu'il ya
quelques années j'étais en train
complètement de me laisser bouffer par
tout se sait et je suis vraiment
aujourd'hui étrangement reconnaissance
n'est pas étrange mais reconnaissant
d'être en vie parce que je me dis
j'aurais pu ne jamais exister mais mes
parents mes grands parents tous morts et
j'en aurais pu ne jamais exister mais
moi je suis là et je suis né dans une
époque
j'arrive à presque 30 ans et j'ai la
chance d'être poète de vivre de mon art
de prendre la parole d'avoir accédé à
des tribunes alors que je sais que
derrière moi il ya toute cette histoire
là de deux tentatives d'assimilation
d'extermination de de se faire faire
taire tc il ya tous ceux et je me dis
justement comment est ce que je fais
chaque jour de ma vie pour être témoins
de ce qui est en même temps construire
ce qui va venir c'est quand même
incroyable que que vous citez malgré
toutes les tentatives d'intimidation des
télésièges finalement de la tentative de
deux tués lundi au coeur de l'enfant
dans gmail que justement la culture sont
encore vivantes puis de l'impression de
plus en plus moi même type i c'est fou
le tri de traverser des siècles
d'oppression lotus et se fait pas du
jour au lendemain loin de l'outil mais
c'est quand même ça ça montre justement
tels mots tantôt une résilience
incroyable puis une force incroyable
puis c'est ce ccc vraiment je la perds
mes mots parce que c'est tellement
triste et d'autres voulaient seulement
exister seulement vivre tripy seulement
vie votre culture on connaît on essayait
de de vous enlever ce droit le lot le
plus
fondamental le tien puis je l'écouté
justement le documentaire de desjardins
dans les derniers jo pis si on voit les
conditions dans lesquelles les gens
vivent dans certains réservent répit ça
fait mal c'est vraiment difficile à voir
qui tue je comprends pas comment on peut
raisonner quoi que ce soit par rapport à
sauter comment comment tu peux te dire
que c'est que c'est correct qu'il ya des
gens qui vivent ici comment tu peux
l'expliquer et idir payer des gens qui
sont à 100 m il y habite a 100 mètre du
barrage hydroélectrique ne sont pas
plugin sur l'électricité et puis on peu
d'eau potable tpiy je comprends pas que
steam
comment tu peux cesser de raisonner
je pense que poser la question non c'est
camilla jose padilla veut dire pas de
raisonnement non mais le team et on ne
voit pas légal c'est comme les personnes
qui prennent des décisions je vois pas
l'égal des personnes qui pour qui sur
qui préside dans l'e-mail se sont posé
des questions au parlement où jean-paul
il y avait créé toutes sortes de raisons
historiques ou des raisons légales des
raisons si ce métier c'est un sujet
d'une question de dignité humaine de
base mais pis si je pense pas que c'est
vrai qu'on que ça serait plus je pense
que ce serait difficile tant que ce on
avait les moyens de faire que ces gens
le vivent dans des conditions décentes
chrétien puis vraiment des conditions
qui ne tique s'apparente ou à des pays
tels vraiment dé favoriser le tri puis
ça se passe ici
là se pose pas si loin d'être cependant
espèce de 2,2 nord flou le ticket convoi
pour le département le titre de ce
fameux le peuple invisible c'est super
fort parce que du point de vue du blanc
qui grandit à montréal qui rendent à
québec grandi c'est vraiment se sait
comme il y peu de dialogue il pas dans
nos discussions n'y a pas des changes
c'est comme nous on fait notre affaire
j'ai douté
oui mais encore puis on vous voit pas
pipi ces deux sites
tu parlais tantôt que la réécriture de
l'histoire c'est une des pistes de
solution si c'est quoi les eaux c'est
quoi les autres pistes de solution c'est
que quand même à partir de lol c'est à
partir d'aujourd'hui on à paul content
mais on a évidemment aller aux urnes
voter quand ce sera le temps de voter
pour vos idéaux politiques mais j'ai du
ghsr aux gens qui nous écoutent les mai
mai sinon si on passe pas par le
changement de gouvernement dans
l'immédiat qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait ou par où on passe c'est quoi la
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
puis j'étais la question est vraiment
large mais c'est parce que on dirait que
voudrait que je le vois pas le rapport
avoir des discussions comme ceux ci n'en
parlait mais encore le je trouve que
c'est tellement et sait rien et si dans
le fond c'est que c'est quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire par où ça passe
le juste c'est pis encore le sepa sepa
notamment la réconciliation comme tout
est en taule c'est vraiment nex les vols
comment est ce que on fait juste juste
vivre pour que tout le monde soit
l'outil les et feront du passé sont
derrière sont fait c'est fait des dons
c'est terrible c'est odieux on peut en
reparler à l'infini mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est rendu l'eau
aujourd'hui je pense que avec les
derniers mots de françois legault
c'est vraiment clair que ça nous
appartient à la population du repos
décisions drastiques aussi fermement de
l'acca 15 mai et on va laisser au chef
le soin de discuter avec les ministres
et le gouvernement et de notre côté je
l'impression moi c'est sur l'art et la
culture les arts et la culture reste le
dernier
bastion par lequel on peut on peut
rentrer dans le jeu de c est dans ce
sens que maintenant le cinéma est aussi
beaucoup plus accessible maintenant
c'est d'être capable de faire des vidéos
de prendre la parole aussi sur ces
questions là on a vraiment accès à
toutes ces informations
toutes ces conversations là ils sont
déjà en ligne au site et non qu'on peut
vraiment aller s'éduquer mais je reviens
souvent au numérique mais on peut
vraiment tenté déjà de s'éduquer d'abord
avec l'aide du numérique mais aussi
entre nous mais aussi comment est ce
qu'on fait pour en pleine pandémie poser
ces questions le perdre ses
conversations là mais je pense que quand
même s'il faut les avoir en ligne mais
aussi par la création de l'homme je vois
maintenant que la vidéo est vraiment
très très efficace mais aussi la fiction
la littérature parce que j'ai avec une
des neuf jets j'ai fait l'expérience de
faire vivre un personnage c'est que que
ce qui est un ensemble de plusieurs
personnes que j'ai connues donc de leur
donner une voix j'avais l'impression
d'être plusieurs femmes à la fois dans
mon corps dedans un seul personnage qui
1 dans les années qui ont suivi j'ai dès
que je sortais de la maison puis même si
je dans un quartier de montréal où je me
disais les gens écoutent pas telle issue
je me fais arrêter dans la rue
mais je me faisais arrêter constamment
dans la rue j'en ai fait l'anxiété
sociale mais genre constamment partout
au québec eut plus je m'éloigne est
justement en région plus que les faits
étaient vraiment là non puis je me suis
dit ça fait des amis que j'utilise les
communications les médias les les
les salons du livre les conférences
comme médium d'expression de ses piles
heures le spectacle la poésie mais tout
d'un coup la fiction est venu changer
tellement quand tu peux pas c'est juste
un petit message mais à quelque chose de
hull trop mainstream
ça peut avoir un effet bien plus fort
que tu te ment métriques un message
super force particulièrement attendu par
mois une personne ses pieds puis 6,6 il
démarre dans un sens mais c'est comme
des petites victoires des petites
batteries la fois tu y es tu toi méthode
quand tu veux te tenir ce rôle le dessus
hésiter oui c'est même encore
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui c'est sûr
je dirais non parce qu'on est pure en
tulle ne sais pas si l'on n'ait rendu
vraiment dans d'en offrir écrire et
offrir des rôles positifs seraient
autant de sécurité à plusieurs acteurs
autochtone qui existe et qui est où elle
même je dire toutes sortes d'autres
roulerait pour des personnes assises et
simplement parce qu'il faut maintenant
illustrer la réalité c'est parce que je
vis négative non c'est simple c'est pas
juste 7 il ya des gens qui travaillent
aussi tiède il ya des gens qui
travaillent à sauver des vies dans les
communautés ça peut être d'excellents
téléroman je pense de d'aller voir
comment que ça se passe réellement
mais il ya des gens aussi qui qui qui
font des initiatives communautaires
extraordinaire ça ça me ferait aussi
d'excellents téléroman des choses comme
ça donc c'est mais à l'époque je m'étais
dit mon dieu c'est sûr que ça va être le
seul personnage autochtones à la télé à
ce moment là c'est moi je me suis dit
j'ai hésité parce que je sais comme
comment que ça se fait que c'est ce
qu'on m'offre c'était encore une junkie
encore une prostituée encore une team
ceux là je me suis dit en même temps oui
mais ces gens là existe aussi des plus
j'ai regardé l'émission c'est surtout
parce que je
j'en avais entendu parler mais je la
connaissais pas parce que justement je
regardais plus la télé québécoise depuis
très longtemps parce que je peux pas me
sentir concerné par ce qui se passe at
il dit
j'ai vu l'émission puis j'ai compris
toute l'humanité derrière justement
l'écriture puis de de vouloir
justement parlez de ces femmes là en
prison qui ont des récits singuliers qui
ne sont pas d'aidé que qui ne sont pas
des criminels dans le fond cccd tout des
victimes de quelque chose et elle ont
elles ne font que survivre et et je me
dis baisse c'est quelque chose auquel je
peux m'identifier dépit mon personnage
dans ce cadre là dans ce contexte l'on
peut fonctionner été et je me suis dit
je pourrais dire non puis j'ai failli
dire non et puis en mai mais en même
temps je venais de rencontrer le
réalisateur jean-philippe duval puis
j'ai senti qu'ils étaient humains et
d'équité qui est qui et qui
entre que j'ai senti une connexion j'ai
rencontré danielle trottier j'ai compris
sa démarche puis je me suis dit oh qu'il
est quand même le bon monde quand même
pour aller là dedans puis en même temps
je sais comme mes joueurs dire non parce
que j'ai peur de faire honte aux gens si
j'avais peur de faire honte
une communauté hippie de doter les gens
me connaissent pour ma poésie mon
écriture mon combat j'avais peur
littéralement de leur faire honte avec
ça et puis en même temps je me suis dit
mais si je refuse c'est sûr c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui va être visitée et
je me dis est ce que cette personne ne
veut avoir le même bagage que moi et sk
va être capable aussi de défendre ce
personnage le comme moi j'ai envie de le
faire ce qu'il est je me serais
questionner puis je me suis dit comment
est ce que j'ai envie de le faire
d'abord puis je me suis dit ça va être
ma chance ou 6 2
en fait mon chum militants mon avis je
défends je veux défendre si voilà je
veux défendre cc j'ai envie de porter
leur voix de ces femmes là qui sont en
milieu carcéral qui sont qui sont
justement dans la rue qui qui qui j'ai
une cousine qui a été longtemps dans la
rue autant à montréal qu'à québec qui
est décédé en 2012 qu'on a retrouvée à
moitié nue dans dans un parking de
québec tpiy donc gg
j'ai connu cette personne là qui qui qui
a cherché à survivre toute sa vie pieds
elle finit par se faire bouffer par
c'est démonter et puis un temps je me
dis mais ce qu'on est voué à ce bain non
aux antilles mais ça existe des gens
comme ça qui sont dans la détresse et
dans dans mes conversations avec les le
real est la scénariste on ne citez moi
je pouvais pas prendre non plus un rôle
qui n'avaient pas de rédemption et et
daniel maudit mais c'est ça que je sais
c'est une émission de télé c'est sûr ça
va être dur parce que c'est une série
était donc s'essayer au on révèle
quelque chose de plus en plus à chaque
fois pour la rédemption
non seul film mais je me suis dit je me
suis dit je vais essayer de les gens
vont en avoir pas au début mai six mois
c'est clair dans ma tête que je sais
qu'au bout c'est ça et que ça va
peut-être donner un effet positif parce
que mes chansons que j'ai vu ce qu'est
ma vie ma carrière
gb oui parce que j'aurais pu comme si
ç'avait été un rôle qui n'a pas de
positif au final samar servir ça
m'aurait servi à rien
exact même si je veux raconter ces
histoires là ça dépend comment les gens
on interprète donc s'il ya pas de
rédemption il ya pas de volonté d'un
personnage à vouloir s'en sortir sa
série teen daze assez simple dans le
scénario laisse un petit mois moi c'est
la rédemption mais mon maman je peux
commander mon cheval de bataille du
préfet met donc j'ai eu tous ceux comme
comme hésitation qui m'ennuie je me suis
dit ben je vais embarquer dedans parce
que j'ai envie de dette cette
personne-là qui a particulier le
contrepoids du personnage est ce que je
me suis dit je suis rendu là dans ma
carrière j'ai g4 livre j'avais déjà moi
j'ai quatre livres puis j'ai cette
carrière le g7 reconnaissance le qui gg
j'ose espérer que aussi mon art se
reflète dans mon interprétation c'est
dans ma volonté d'humaniser ces
personnages là et je prends ce risque
était parce que comme je dis j'aurais pu
perdre toute crédibilité
c est justement plus positif est arrivé
au final et aux finances quand ce qu'on
me dit dans la rue justement que les
gens que j'ai rencontrés puis les gens
qui sont venus voir dans les salons du
livre t il mon dit il mon dit à partir
de maintenant je sais que j'étais
raciste mais à partir de maintenant je
comprends tellement la réalité je l' ai
tellement véhicule avec le personnage
que je peux plus rien dire de mauvais
parce qu'à 10 sam c'est parce que c'est
de l'injustice que vous vivez et
maintenant je milite pour ce genre c'est
quand j'ai pas un spi quand j'en parle
j'ai tout temps les larmes aux yeux
parce que je me dis mon dieu c'est
vraiment le dernier commentaire mais
c'est même pas un commentaire auquel
j'aurais pu m'attendre entend adopter
mais c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'on
pouvait me faire c'est de me dire que
dans tout ce que j'ai risqué
qu'on me dise que ça les hauts faits
shift est ainsi celle là je me suis dit
à qui j'ai réussi mes tirs assure en
même temps et pour ce que je dis que
c'est quand même possible de faire shift
et légendes de d'une position vraiment
harkis parce que c'est l'éducation
qu'ils ont reçu c'est l'éducation par
partez à la maison c'est bien entre les
dans son village je sais pas quoi puis
de simplement avec leurs pieds la
fiction puis c'est à ce moment je me tue
dépôt d'une télésérie pouvait autant et
des ah ça mais ça fait changer des gens
dans leur perception pis je me dis les
arts la culture je pense on vraiment un
énorme pouvoir sur ce parce que les gens
quand ils lisent un livre aucun organe
une télésérie est content de vivre les
choses avec les personnages et autres
ans l'abbé identifiés d'être empathique
sur tout je pense que l'exemple de sa
tâche et puis de fond du problème c'est
le manque d'empathie le manque de
connaissance puis demande à partir
justement télésérie ou qui passent
autant de temps avec un personnage ou un
film ou un livre comme tu dis cécile ça
permet de comprendre qui je pense que
justement c'est comme intelligemment que
moi qui la télé séries6 prise de frire
ce qui à première vue apparaît comme un
stéréotype il déconstruit tranquillement
tpiy le ca fait que tu vas là mais la
personne qui évitait le public d'une des
neuf si le public était québécois moyen
une étude qui disent qu'ils écoutent
seul grand public le terne qui le prend
par la main peut-être que justement
peut-être qu'il y apporter quelque chose
de plus à avancer le sida il répété près
mais probablement que la prochaine
télésérie justement comme si ça serait
le fun d'avoir des personnages ou est-ce
que c'est pas juste le côté sombre de
l'écouté difficile mais aussi la culture
le tri la culture autochtone qui se pâme
qui se parent fait qu'il faut voir plus
je me rappelles tu parles de fiction
pour modifier les perceptions ou du
moins faire avancer les raisonnements
puis la première fois que j'avais lu
moby que c'est ultra n'diaye mais dans
moby dick
il ya un des personnages d'un personnage
ultra important que d'une autochtone
puis c'est le personnage de plus badass
de la littérature
[Rires]
je me rappelle avoir été fasciné par ce
personnage de qui est montré ultra
positivement dans tous et toutes ses
habitudes puisque l'âge vraiment en fait
avec avec les autres personnages de par
sa relation avec avec la mort puis de
commandes la mort et justin la suède de
la vie où tu sais quelque chose de
vraiment naturel sur lequel lui il lutte
pas pour essayer de ne sait pas tout
prix de de résister à la mort puis de
l'empêcher puis comme toute cette
relation là c'est vraiment ultra
intéressant que ça clashe vraiment avec
la vision occidentale des autres
personnages mais toujours dire que c'est
un exemple qui m'est venue quand tu
parlais de fiction pile comment
effectivement ça c'est important
piscine c'est une bonne réflexion une
bonne piste de réflexion
vraiment mais justement je peux ajouter
papa se tire autant ça peut être le
meilleur médium est parmi les meilleurs
médium pour c'est justement amener les
gens à être beaucoup plus empathique à
des à certaines réalités
mais autant la fiction a été le
principal vecteur des clichés et des
stéréotypes de tout hollywood a
participé en fait à créer l'image de
l'indien bharti de l'indien qui n'existe
plus et des plumes sur la tête et donc
dans dans la population c'est l'image
qui restait était donc c'est pour ça
qu'en encore vous on nous demande son
diplôme est ce que tu emportes t ou même
justement de ces cancans voit dans les
paroisses les paroisses et c'est une
réappropriation c'est puis en même temps
pour nous qui ne sommes pas du sud ouest
des états unis
d'où vient d'où vient c'est dans cela
mais on se les approprient même en
sachant que ça vient des autres parce
que une ou l'offre pour qu'on puisse se
rassembler et non qu'il ya ce dialogue
l'est qui se passe entre les
inclinations aussi mais c'est sûr que
c'est c'est
des fois ça ça conforte les gens dans
leur image des autochtones ont commencé
lundi pour des plumes c'est avec les
paroles sont faits cette éducation la
ccc juste des habits de poche juste des
habits d'apparat mais c'est des habits
de cérémonie donc ceci on portait ses
vêtements lost et surtout dans des
moments de fête de célébration de deux
rassemblements donc ce n'était pas tous
les jours qu'on porte et toutes sortes
de tous ces éléments là c'est sûr que
oui avant oui mais aujourd'hui c'est sûr
ça fait pas partie de mes serment de
notre réalité donc cessé il ya toujours
l'éducation à faire douter mais
justement hollywood a encore beaucoup de
la conséquence des défaites dans ce mais
comme j'ai dit je pense qu'encore faut
justement par la fiction renverser tous
mais ça n'est pas ben attia qui qui qui
est le créateur derrière cette fiction
le jeudi aussi les autochtones sont
toujours mis en porte et du patois les
prismes blanc occidental non un problème
c'est ça c'est des centaines la question
de dépression culturel le t6 si le
créateur en arrière de tout ce un mal
informés ou aient des billets ou un peu
de respect envers c'est la communauté
qui qui eût qui met à l'écran qui met à
l'écriture c'est sûr que ce repos très
bénéfique le sait puis le fait qu'ils
mettront toi tu étais tu étais prêt at
il ajouté
tous joué le rôle d'une autochtone pitt
était militante
t'aurais pas laisser passer quelque
chose
leur exemple quitte à accepter ou six
parce que cet effet avec respect et
parlement avec avec un recherche au site
si ça n'avait pas été le cas mais je
pense que les piéger en a travaillé
ensemble sur les cépages or je joue le
personnage que quelqu'un d'autre a écrit
mais on le modelé ensemble
disons que ça a été quand même c'est
assez je pense une position privilégiée
mais comme unique ne s'est pas tous les
comédiens les acteurs qui ont le la
chance d'avoir ce de pouvoir contribuer
à 7 mai et donc j'ai eu cette chance le
puits en même temps je sais que dans le
milieu c'est justement c'est sûr on est
en plein dans ceux des bolts et dans
mille et de la télévision de la fiction
des téléséries ccc souvent j'ai des
jeunes actrices et je me sens aimé mais
ceux qui viennent de commencer c'est
pour l'heure dit laisse jamais personne
ne te questionner sur ce que toi tu sais
c'est sur ton propre peuple
ta propre langue qui se savait pas dire
que tout le monde doit faire ça tous les
scénaristes et risquent d'imposer ou les
réels risquent d'imposer mais il ya
toujours un risque quand même et je le
redis ici ici ici n'ai pas peur de dire
que c'est c'est pas authentique séné
loin parce que si tu as ta communauté
que que tu dois de 2,2 de jeu pour
démentir de portrait tease et à ta
communauté que tu dois t'y de ce
personnage là je pense que je peux
comment dire de quel côté mais de dire
ça c'est si tu joues malheureusement non
on dirait une certaine responsabilité
était de 2 qu'est ce que ce qu'elle est
quel que soit le personnage qu'on joue
on a une responsabilité envers nos
communautés parce qu'on est dans ces
enjeux-là de représentation de
représentativité parce qu'aussi
dépendamment de qu'est-ce qu'on
interprète ça ça peut continuer à jouer
soit dans nos propres perceptions par
rapport à nous-mêmes ou dans la
perception de la population qui
regardent la télévision manque si je
trouve que c'est vraiment très complexe
et puis aussi parce qu'il ya encore et
si on me permet de lire plusieurs
projets mais il ya encore des moments où
on souhaite m'imposer une boisson
décrire le personnage alors que moi je
suis là pour consulter pour en tant que
consultante pour leur faire des
propositions et qu'on refuse ces
propositions neige comme un l'on pourra
pas avancer de cépie et à ce moment là
je dis si vous voulez pas travailler
puis si vous prenez pas les
recommandations
c'est pas juste moi qui les fais c'est
moi qui l'ait fait à partir de ce que je
sais qui se fait ailleurs c'est donc ccc
ccc répandue les propositions que je
vous fais sont répandues c'est juste que
le livre n'est pas écrite vous avez pas
encore la preuve tangible mais ici on
refuse j'ai tendance à m'opposer à la
création d'un personnage ou à la
création d'une émission parce que je
trouve que ce n'est pas fait dans ce que
ça devrait pas donc dans le respect dans
les côtes et donc souvent ils veulent
simplement je sais pas y aller mais tu
es si c'est simplement soit répondra à
ce qui se passe en ce moment où on
répondra à leurs publics cocher une case
ih oui mais heureusement on est à une
heure où est ce que quand 6 po fé avèk
connaissance puis avec respect on ne
laisse pas passer
oui exact je sais pas je sais plus juste
aux activistes ont militants des
communautés à dire comme défendre même
pas juste mais pas activiste même temps
on est juste comme juste des gens la
population comme mais le soc pas correct
dit à ce moment avant quand on disait ça
on était a baissé à brouiller
on était comme maintenant vous parler
tout croche c'est pas vrai et c'est raté
mais maintenant là le public lui même le
dit et même l'expriment sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont indiqué que ses potes
antique
c'est donc s'y mettant les compagnies de
production souhaite justement faire le
portrait ou répondre à la
représentativité mais ils doivent savoir
que quand ils disent que le public n'est
pas prêt à sony ne veut pas seulement
soit ou ne pourrait pas prendre tel
genre de personnage
moi je leur réponds non c'est toi parce
que m
oui c'est ça au contraire si j'ai la
chance comme je disais de faire les
salons du livre est tout ça donc souvent
les livres c'est lié aussi au téléroman
les gens qui regardent clairement vont
lire un peu plus tôt des romans sinon
qui donc je rencontre ces gens là aussi
dans la rue puis ils me disent qu'ils
sont prêts puis attendre que ce qu'ils
espèrent qu'il y en ait plus c'est le
nombre de fois comme l'a dit mais quand
j'arrive devant des productions qui me
disent non c'est pas ce qu'ils veulent
comme vous êtes vraiment déconnecté de
votre public l'un pipi à la limite
prenez dont un risque que dans
l'hexagone et dans le pire des cas types
rené dont un risque dans bones si vous
savez que c'est la bonne chose à faire
soyez donc plus audacieux pipi fait le
tri au lieu de penser à rome et le t1
telle une telle est allé me repose pieds
pas prête à voir ce type de match un peu
plus près tarsus de passer connaître ce
que les gens veulent piller veulent voir
qu'ils sont pas prêts à voir dans ce
sens qu'ils sous-estiment et
l'intelligence des desjardins tripy
jeudi malgré tout malgré que du racisme
haïr aidera système et que je pense que
les gens québec
tessi pour la plupart des gens ouverts
le pigeon va d'esprit picchi des gens
qui sont qu'ils sont sont capables dans
la d'envoi piller bien aidé il y en a
une méchante bonne gagne aussi qu'ils
sont très sympathiques là à voir les
autochtones seppi qui veulent qu'ils
veulent juste quelques la culture
rayonne qui vous était pas ce que je
peux encore une fois j'ai appris mon
métier c'est parce que je pense que les
gens sont prêts puis je pense qu'on a
besoin de spis sont pas prêts mais je
pense que je suis fou il faut faire un
pot à l'avant malgré tout bien tout les
comme un besoin d'audace
je pense que c'est l'air du temps aussi
mais c'est aussi posé les bonnes bases
pour la prochaine génération se sait
tout ce qu'on fait là c'est pour la
prochaine génération 6 essais je suis
pour l'avenir du québec sq pour l'avenir
de notre population sait pour qui et qui
se sent bien qu'ils se sentent écoutés
qui qui qui qui a aussi l'accès à son
esprit critique si je pense que c'est ce
qui qui revient souvent 6e
j'ai l'impression des fois que ce qu'on
a eu comme des boks ont assez polarisant
c'est juste souci le besoin d'avoir le
besoin d'avoir sa propre opinion c'est
aussi le besoin d'avoir accès à cet
esprit c'est clair
alors quand on nous en moulant 5 pop on
ne le donne pas l'esprit critique dont
j'ai l'impression donc que tout ce qu'on
a l'impression d'être de voir comme
polarisant donc de dire que mon dieu ccc
mauvais ce qui se passe en vérité pour
moi j'entends plutôt un besoin qui ce
qu'ils aient crié d'avoir accès à ce
cette capacité de réfléchir d'analyser
la situation et de les rationaliser et y
est je dirais on en ont fait aujourd'hui
on fait toujours ça mais si on n'éduque
pas cessé sa population c'est seulement
des saveurs justement ressortir tout
croche mais justement si on va se donner
la peine d'aller donnés cette éducation
l'ajustement de réécrire l'histoire
d'aller chercher ailleurs qu est ce qui
se fait à pied cc c'est aimer son peuple
c'est de lui donner ça cc c'est comme
par exemple de mon côté je sais qu'on
n'a pas toujours accès à l'éducation
quand on se sent tellement comme petit
quand on va à l'école genre cégep et
l'université on sent pas capable de
finir au ccc on a l'impression que c'est
pas pour nous l'éducation alors que de
mon côté 10 et j'ai eu mon éducation en
écrivant des livres c'est drôle mais
c'est ça vient et ensuite en
m'intéressant à d'autres littératures
pierre murray intéressant qui est la
mienne ça la littérature autochtones du
canada du québec des états unis je sais
c est moi je me dis juste que j'ai envie
c'est que j'aime tellement justement
j'aime tellement mon peuple que je veux
aussi qu'ils qui lisent d'autres
littératures qui lisent un peu plus donc
c'est je suis devenu semi traductrice
dans les dernières années pour qu'on a
accès à certains livres dit qu'ils sont
écrits du côté anglophone puis qu'on
peut savoir si ces sujets là ici aussi
je pensais quand je donne des
conférences je parle de caisse que j'ai
vus ailleurs
et puis je fais dès qu'on n'est pas des
comparaisons mais je fais des liens avec
ce qu'on a ici
puis quand je retourne chez nous je
parle de ces deux sites de cette affirmé
on l'a conduit à prendre mais aussi de
cette fierté locon en cultiver à propos
de notre propre philosophie était
justement la relation territoire la
politique de la relation territoire
c'est une philosophie de base ses skis
au mode line nos modes de vie pendant
des siècles des millénaires lundi et est
que même malgré tout ce qui se passe
dans la réalité ces six millénaires le
sont encore dans nos corps qui ont les
recréer s'est constamment nos ci par là
c'est en train de cession de sa
s'exprime beaucoup plus mais si on peut
amener ces dans d'autres sphères c'est
comme l'éducation comme les services
sociaux comme la santé et tout seul la
politique si on est capable moi mon rêve
ultime c'est qu'on soit capable de
réhabiliter nos propres structures au
sein de nos communautés entre nos
communautés entre les nations puis je
sais ça va ça vous créé tellement de
changements mais ça va créer tellement
aussi de deux ça vous donne une
population qui s'affirme et qui se
laisse pas marcher sur les pieds du tout
ce que tu faisais aussi à la culture
générale tu médites veut dire que vous
ayez vos propres systèmes politiques
finalement oui parce que par exemple je
donne un petit exemple mais puisque je
promettant de mon temps là dessus mais
c'est le conseil de bande ça a été
imposée par la loi sur les indiens
c'est un modèle non autochtone comme
qu'on nous annonce et ce alors que
traditionnellement le modèle de
politique de leadership est complètement
différente c'est le lidl n'est pas un
leader et c'est plutôt celui qui porte
la parole la communauté donc c'est un
porte parole en quelque sorte mais c'est
la communauté qui prend ses décisions
pour elle même parce que c'est ça cc
c'est celle là c'est sûr là le nomadisme
même la soumission sédentarisation nous
nous contacter nous nous nous a donné
ces structures là mais on on se
structure le suivent aussi les cycles de
la nature les écosystèmes et tout ça
donc c'est quelque chose de complètement
organique de moi j'appelle ça une
politique organique de 2 de revenir à
cette formule le cercle les 10 le
concept c'est vraiment comme dans la
politique organique
c'est si si tu laisses quelqu'un de
coûts
t'es tu met en péril la communauté au
complet si tu laisses pas une personne
contribué aux connaissances générales
aux halles à l'éducation aussi tu lui
donnes pas l'éducation que la communauté
peut lui donner c'est pas simplement
parce que cette personne nous existons
pas communauté si tu la mets de côté tu
te met en péril tachimoto complet je
leur dis mais c'est c'est cyclique que
c'est quoi la preuve mais c'est si tu
oublies quelqu'un tu peux mourir tu es
donc cesser ces mêmes puces comme je
disais il ya l'état de prédation dans
les dents dans lequel on peut se trouver
du liquide dans les premiers états de
l'ue mais j'ai l'impression que donald
dans sa survie et tout ça mais il y
avait aussi les taux de survie dans la
nature qui a permis en fait la lasse de
structurer un modèle de politique parce
que la politique à la base est aussi la
définition des relations de les
individus d'un même groupe s'est donc
cesser ce qui est défini une nounou
politique c'est vraiment de suivre
l'écosystème parce que si on ne suit pas
l'écosystème autour de nous notre
environnement
on risque d'en de mourir aussi tu sais
si on va à l'encontre de la nature on va
mourir c'est donc je pense pour ce que
je vois comme la cité dans comment il
est aujourd'hui comment est-ce qu'on est
en vert et contre la nature comment est
ce qu'on tente de passer au travers des
changements climatiques ce qui se font
déjà sentir
c'est comme si de rien n'était et de
retrouver notre confort à chaque fois
qu'il la tempête est passé c'est de
tenir dix comme je reviens encore la
surconsommation c'est un symptôme de
cette déstabilisation le concept qui
arrive avec les changements tu es donc
c'est si on on réhabilite pas justement
pour nous dans nos communautés ces
structures le on risque nous même de
n'être jamais réellement racine était
alors que réhabiliter les structures
anciennes d'éducation de politique de
l'oci de réflexion de deux philosophies
et du terrain si déjà en quelque sorte
garantir notre survie dans la société
d'aujourd'hui tu d'instaurer ce [ __ ]
n'habitez aa coexistant dans
dans l'occident ou est-ce que le modèle
capitaliste le t1 modèle occidental tout
ça m'apparaît très la feinte de passe et
on en a reçu l'une maurice denis fortin
scipion de questionner toutes sortes de
ces choses-là de céder ses cibles qui
sont implantées puis qu'on prend pour
acquis qu'on questionne pas toujours le
théo d'études et de l'économie comment
ça fonctionne pitt est tout ce qu'il ya
beaucoup d' absurdité je pense l'équité
des systèmes qui ont été érigées puis le
songe c'est juste comme ceux qui
questionnent puis mix qui font aucun
sens ou du moins sur le long terme qui
font confiance
sauf que on dirait que c'est
excessivement difficile de décider de
plus jouer avec les règles des règles de
non moi je refuse ce système là je
refuse de participer
puis je décide de vie selon un mode de
vie alternatif a sauté dit comment tu
vois sur une espèce de monde ou est ce
que justement vous ramener celle-ci met
méthodes de fonctionner plus ancestrales
mais entouré d'une meute de occidental
qui fonctionne existait vraiment
implanté vrai qu'ils sont là pour rester
quand même le temps est ce que c'est
possible que demande le co existent dans
une harmonie mais je pense que je pense
que au final oui parce que de notre côté
ce système leur extérieur capitaliste eu
des conséquences néfastes sur nos
populations et réhabiliter nos
structures anciennes ou traditionnelles
qu'on peut contemporain analyser des dit
qu'on peut mettre au goût du jour en
quelques sortes et est adapté au monde
dans lequel on est mais si du moins on
peut réhabiliter ces structures le sait
déjà réhabilité une partie de notre
identité et est donc c'est aussi si on
rêve notre identité six essais
si réhabiliter notre survie cccc ce truc
structurer notre survie au sein d'un
monde qui n'est pas le nôtre c'est et
donc c'est déjà pour moi mes yeux nous
renforcer par rapport à un monde que
comme juste et de danser ça va ce monde
dans lequel on vit
et pour moi je vois ça comme dédé déjà
les commenter fonctionne presque comme
des microsociétés zeus et c'est
justement parce qu'il ya la mer qui
n'est pas un autre ticket qui est tout
autour de chaque communauté
on a déjà la [ __ ] et là la poste la
capacité de fonctionner ensemble même si
on n'est pas directement connectée dit
jeudi au dessus d'un village à un nom tu
as déjà trois villes québécoises c'est à
dire ça fait déjà partie de notre
réalité et aussi de notre adaptation
c'est est donc juste réhabiliter ces
politiques là par exemple concernant
commenté ccc répondre à un grand besoin
de guérir ce que ce que la société
extérieure nous nous fait c'est comme
com
comme je peux vraiment dire comme grands
motets et ici il renforcer notre
capacité à mon dieu je sais pas comment
l'expliquer mais c'est si si si on
arrive à survivre on est déjà beaucoup
plus forts fait que c'est ce avec notre
capacité à fonctionner que les autres
communautés
si sûr ça va se faire tout seul et à
partir de ce moment le nous on sera déjà
beaucoup plus fort pour négocier pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'on veut retirer des
négociations pour pour aller chercher
d'autres bouts de territoire que nous
ancêtres parcourait parce qu'on serait
en voie est encore plus en mesure de
protéger ses environnements le de
protéger ces territoires le et si un
jour on peut les réutiliser par exemple
aller chercher des médecines
traditionnelles non peu réinstaurer
aussi notre notre propre mode de santé
était ancien pilote la mélanger avec la
médecine moderne dénoncer c'est aussi
quand on a des structures comme ça c'est
aussi amener de donner du travail aux
gens s'ils donnent une ce travail à des
à des guides spirituels qui vont pas
juste travailler sur justement comme les
professionnels la santé il sur le corps
ils vont aussi de travailler de façon
holistique donc à ce moment là ça va
juste répondre déjà à notre besoin
promis c'est c'est d'être de redevenir
entier pour nous d'abord et à partie ce
moment là les relations entre cultures
ce ne seront que meilleurs c'est parce
qu'il n'y aurait plus eu ce rapport de
domination
il y aurait ignoré à partir de ce moment
là qu'un rapport des gays d'égal à égal
et donc à ce moment là la conversation
sera beaucoup plus facile
j'ai l'impression que tu es un des
problèmes c'est qu'ils aient pas de
délimitation claire des territoires
finalement c'est dans ce sens qu'on on
partage un territoire et certaines zones
qui sont dits qu'ils saison 2 le
appartiennent si vous autochtone se mais
n'empêche que si on décide comporte sa
part plein le compenser par une lampe
dati s'est payé pour amant de discussion
tant que ceo de négociations tant que ça
j'ai l'impression t qui se serait
cohabiter j'avais posé la question à un
métier qui était venu pipe
puis je pense que tout a commencé à y
répondre mais ce serait quoi telle
espèce de
utopie de vivre ensemble c'est entre
justement les lits des différentes
cultures pour que tout le monde peut
s'épanouir et puis tout le monde
puissent coexister ça c est ce que c'est
plus d'indépendance est ce que c'est ce
que senna indépendance parce que total
des autochtones ou au contraire cessé
plus de charge ces poteries commencé
voici une espèce de caisse qui est
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce que vous
voulez finalement qu'est-ce que moi mon
rêve c'est comme si je n'aime pas appelé
c'est une utopie mis en quelque sorte
c'en est une mais je crois quand même
que ses possibilités c'est vraiment
d'arriver à une indépendance économique
pour chaque communauté
une complète indépendance ou 6,1 par
rapport à l'éducation par rapport aux
services sociaux et à tous les services
publics en général mais à toutes sortes
d'autres choses c'est qui qui qui qui
peuvent exister pour nous qui n'existent
pas nécessairement pour la société
québécoise ou canadienne c'est donc pour
tous les non autochtones et des choses
pour nous qui existe qui n'existe pas
pour les noms de tonnes donc si nous on
est indépendants on va pouvoir insérer
dans nos communautés des structures qui
qui qui nous sied encore plus mais qui
font partie de notre logique de witte
qui sont aussi représentatif de notre
philosophie traditionnelle et moi je
vois par exemple skieurs comme comme
réserves ce qui a été délimité par la
couronne britannique qui était légué par
la couronne qui est d'imiter un aussi
avec le fédéral ce que le fédéral nous
nous a laissé moi je vois plutôt comme
il ya des cons et des communautés au
pied des premières nations au canada qui
vont revendiquer aussi certaines parties
de ces comme des extension de ce qu'ils
ont comme réserves et parce que ce sont
des territoires qui font partie de
l'histoire de la communauté étaient
souvent les communautés par exemple si
on prend les commandes et de la cour
donnant toutes les communautés nous sont
au bord du fleuve
mais c'était tout les campements d'été
traditionnels ou les bandes se s'arrêter
s'arrêter l'été pour se reposer mis
ensuite à tous les chemins de portage
qui monte jusqu'au nord est en fait si
on pouvait simplement revendiquer
certains pans de territoire juste pour
protéger ces chemins de portage le parce
qu'ils sont encore ils ont tellement été
tapée on
suivi les mêmes chemins pendant des
millénaires et il existe encore des
scissions voit dans le bois puis que les
gens savent si sûr que ça se trouve on
peut voir que c'est oui c'est ça oui
exact et pour nous - mes yeux ça fait
partie du patrimoine matériel t on peut
pas dire que c'est immatériel sellette
et ça fait partie de notre patrimoine
immatériel matériel oui mais ça fait
partie pour moi mes yeux du patrimoine
canadien aussi de sauvegarder les
chemins portage et et pour nous ça va
nous servir aussi pour continuer à
parcourir le territoire même si c'est au
delà nos codes de nos communautés
au delà de nos territoires quand comme
peut-être qu'on aurait revendiqué réussi
à obtenir par exemple ccc ici pour moi
je vois une cohabitation assez saine et
harmonieuse à partir du moment où nous
on a accès justement à ces pans de notre
histoire
puis qu'on reconnaît cette histoire leur
pic à pas son nom les négociations pour
cohabiter sur telle pente territoire
mais ils vont se faire de façon beaucoup
plus beaucoup moins difficile parce que
justement s'il ya la reconnaissance ce
patrimoine l'est de cette histoire là
les choses vont aller beaucoup mieux
oui c'est ça on sera pas déjà en état de
conflits dit et je me dis appartement
lieu de qu'est ce qu'on a comme un
territoire qu'est ce qu'on a comme
ressource sur ce territoire là ça va
dépendre de chacun monte comment ils
vont vouloir pour nous ce sera pas
exploité mais certaines communautés ils
vont aller avec l'exploitation mais pour
nous comment est-ce qu'on va les
utiliser c'est vous en partie oui exact
c'est donc qu'il y ait ce qu'il y à un
partage aussi des ressources de quelle
façon ça va être si par exemple les
traiter dans l'histoire du canada donne
n'ont jamais été respectées comment est
ce que nous soyons signent des ententes
postmoderne j'irai le dit comment est ce
qu'on veut les faire respecter des deux
côtés de dépendamment est justement qui
vit encore dans les conséquences
coloniale ou pas ou ou écoles ou ou pas
dans le sens où est décolonisé t il va
avoir toujours ces questions le mets moi
j'imagine une cohabitation territoriale
ou une cogestion des territoires comme
ça je pense à peu prendre beaucoup
beaucoup dany de travail entre justement
le goût
moment en place mais aussi je pense même
les partis d'opposition devraient faire
partie de ces négociations et cessa de
parce que ça va leur servir et il se
pourrait aussi pour mieux comprendre et
dynamique entre les premières nations et
le gouvernement ou les gouvernements au
travers des années mais je vois vraiment
pour nous l'essentiel ce sera
l'indépendance et nous on avant la
colonisation savait comment fonctionner
entre entre peuple s'il y avait des
politiques différentes par rapport soit
c'est en communauté soit avec d'autres
nations puis avec certaines nations
c'était différent les relations du doigt
qui est de quitter très solide oui c'est
ça qui était partagé t2 de façon assez
quoi qu'on en dise à ses harmonieuse
dépendamment des nations et est par
exemple pour les inouk l'écrit c'est
assez facile parce qu'il la ligne de
partage des eaux trial il ya les
montagnes chi chi chi chi chi des
limites clairement les territoires mais
dans l'histoire même des peuples dits
city on parle souvent de la langue d'une
automatique et qui existaient qui n'est
ni le cri ni lui ni nous la niche nabé
qui qu'on parlait mais c'était une
langue spécifique à aux chasseurs qui
parlaient entre eux tiki kick
après je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui
disparu en quelque sorte mais certains
aînés je pense on a encore la mémoire
mais il ya dans cette histoire là il ya
ça aussi c'est et je me dis si on
reconnaisse
puis quand on vit avec cette
connaissance le savent a tellement
changé au niveau des relations entre
entre nous tout ce que moi je vois que
cette possibilité le petit c'est bizarre
mais je vais jamais sur cette
question-là d'habitude mais je me dis si
un jour on à l'indépendance au québec
si je trouve qu'on aurait la chance de
recréer des systèmes que déjà des pays
comme les les uns comme les pays
scandinaves ou d'autres petits pays ont
réussi à instaurer chez eux jouent comme
la nouvelle zélande on en a à peu près
la même population
dans les 8 millions environ donc à
petite échelle on serait capable de
recréer un système qui qui sied à tout
le monde s'y met on fait d'amis oui
exact et je pense qu'on aurait la
capacité de créer quelque chose de neuf
tués et j'ai l'impression donc je vois
ça comme une gouvernance à deux voix de
ceux ci ont on départage les territoires
et les ressources entre les nations et
le joue à dire la nation québécoise mais
puisqu'on le fait de façon assez non
conflictuelle des donc peut-être pas
harmoniser tout le temps mais tu sais
pas si aider les arias de l'histoire au
city qui est allé ou a tellement menti
en ce que ça peut être ça risque d'être
difficile mais si en bout de l'est on
arrive à se partagent le ici on donne
l'indépendance aux communautés et puis
aux nations je pense qu'à partie ce
moment là pour moi soucier l'utopie
total 10 et la finale pis si je vis
assez longtemps pour le voir je vais me
dire ok je vois mourir en paix dans ce
sens que je le sens que ça pourrait se
faire
l'eia des nations qui ont déjà travaillé
sur des plans comme ça il ya des jeunes
qui imaginent d'indépendance comme ça tu
es y aider c'est déjà dans nos têtes
c'est déjà concept existe mais c'est un
outil de partage des territoires
existait déjà avant la colonisation de
la cohabitation entre les peuples ça
existait déjà donc on fait juste comme
encore une fois ramené ses six concepts
et modèles du passé puis on les met sur
la table qui ont dit qu'est ce qui
pourrait nous nous aller à nous
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans lequel on
se trouve ce québec là que tu décris
c'est pour boucler la boucle ça prend ça
va prendre un gouvernement qui est de
bonne foi qui reconnaît son histoire qui
reconnaissent l injustice piqué puis qui
a un ministre farouk tonnes qui
peut-être autochtones ou du moins qui
aurait qui a un intérêt vers l'été de
l'implication avant de laisser partir la
journée est-ce que tu retournes
notez qu'ils doivent naître oui
normalement je retourne au moins une
fois par année dans ce sens que j'ai été
séparé de ma communauté plus jeune mais
je suis retourné à 18 ans vivre là-bas
pendant un moment puis ensuite quand je
suis parti aux études de rimouski
c'était juste l'autre bord du fleuve
donc je retournais à pca m quand même
tous les étés donc pendant quatre ans au
moins j'ai fréquenté ma communauté de
façon très assidus qui c'est sûr ça a
été le plus grand bien que ça me fais
dans ma vie c'est justement comme je
disais à 16 ans j'avais l'impression
qu'ils m'ont d'être blanche c'est
vraiment chaud j'avais pokes à quel
point je savais pas que j'étais
autochtone
puis retour retourner dans mon village
ça a été toute cette espèce de
reformatage le choc a expliqué dd le
phare qui occupent des couilles de me
réapproprier qui je suis réellement
inquiet puis je range mon dieu n'aimait
de re découvrir qui je suis réellement
envie de faire avec ma personnalité
parce que ce sont des traits culturels
que j'ai que qui donc desquels je suis
vraiment fier et est aujourd'hui je
pense à fait partie un peu de l'image
que j'aime et je comptant d'une once ans
cuche
moi je pense content de poids de faux
secret d'être authentique d'avoir la
chance de vivre qui je suis depuis
d'aussi porter ma culture qui mon
identité de façon aussi public c'est à
dire un mot je suis une fille je suis
fier de l'être
puis je suis fier de le dire et donc
plus que je le dis mais est-ce que c'est
difficile j'ai tout donné mon village
s'ils délivrent à montréal de te sentir
loin de séquelles sur le peut la vivre
au jour le jour
c'est ce que c'est dur c'est ce que je
voulais amener pas parler pour parler
tout le temps si on avait une forme non
parce que j'ai l'impression d'avoir de
la vivre chez moi tu es dedans
ma maison je n'appartenais passe ma
maison c'est dans ma maison pic de deux
ans et puis c'est ça je le fais pas
parce que jésus rejet comme une image
romantiser de ma culture je le fais
parce que c'est moi c'est ce que j'aime
c'est ce qu'est c'est ce qui me fait
sentir bien c'est ce qui c'est ce qui me
parla à moitié puis pas comment dire
c'est justement mais c'est comme je
devais revenir dans mon village ça a été
la chose la plus importante parce que je
me demande encore si je l'aï je l'avais
pas fait ou est ce que j'en serai dans
ma vie c'est dans ma perception de mon
identité puis de ma personne mais tu
viens pour moi pour le milton que tu
aujourd'hui c'est ça ce serait du tout
la même personne oui et donc autant ça
m'apporte ses combos le sait qu'ils
peuvent être vraiment lourd s'en vient
au début tu vois la question ce début
mai autant si c'est la chose qui qui qui
comment dire c'est qu'en fait c'est ça
ça me donne tellement de force pigé je
pense que je m'identifie aussi comme
comme une femme de ma nation en cdd je
veux devenir un pilier je veux être ce
transmetteur 7 transmetteur de deux
d'enseignement jeu ce que je reçois
comme comme enseignement et réflexion je
veux leur donner à d'autres c'est tout
aussi ces notions le de partage de
d'empathie d'authenticité qui sont là
aussi que j'ai reçu comme valeurs
d'intégrité d'être honnête d'être à un
blitz toutes ces valeurs le jeu léché ri
tellement parce que je me dis on a
tellement besoin de deux valeurs comme
ça en plus dans le monde dans lequel on
se trouve aujourd'hui et ma culture est
tellement riche ma philosophie est
tellement riche pied donc elle me fait
vivre à chaque jour tu sais comme
justement c'est pourquoi pourquoi avoir
entre d'être autochtone à thé alors que
oui s'il y en a qui dira m haies et des
raisons d'avoir en moi je dis
juste l'histoire qui vous donne ce tcc
c'est pas ce que ton identité de ton
identité te donne tu sais donc pourquoi
avoir honte
si cette identité et elle m'en fiche
et elle parle aussi aux autres identités
et et il ya une question qu'on n'a pas
abordé c'est aussi être autochtone dans
le monde aujourd'hui c'est c'est dans ce
sens que avec le avec la poésie je me
sens du compte qu'il ya d'autres peuples
autochtones dans le monde et est en
voyage ans j'ai toujours voulu
rencontrer les autres peuples
autochtones et finalement il ya
tellement de points communs de choses
communes d'enseignement commun de
l'histoire de récits et et on partage
sur des mythologies par exemple on les
fait dialoguer et l'armée permet de
faire c'est aussi d'avoir des rencontres
interculturelles autochtone dont
internations c'est pas juste
international met un terme à sion et je
sais ça me samo same enrichit aussi cinq
ans et mon bagage de vie pied cc je vis
de ces rencontres là en fait donc
finalement être autochtone c'est aussi
tout se sait c'est de continuer à
voyager mais de connecter avec les
autres cultures d'une façon tellement
humaine tellement empathique tellement
vrai je trouve donc c'est je voudrais
pas être autre chose
merci infiniment parlé c'était
réellement plaisir j'ai eu beaucoup de
plaisir aussi à discuter